hey what's up everybody welcome back
to another saturday morning vfx stream
my name is clinton jones
and i hope that over you know the course
of this year
we've all learned a lot i've been doing
this every single saturday since march
basically since the since the lockdown
um and we've been we've been going a
while consistently so i really
appreciate you guys coming back every
single time um if you're new to all of
this i hope there's a whole you know
there is a whole wealth of videos going
back all the way to march um i'm in
cinema 4d but i know a lot of you guys
are in blender and can still apply that
same knowledge to uh
you know
to your software of choice
so today we are specifically talking
about
lighting um how to get that
nice renaissance style soft light kind
of look um and we'll also be talking
about talking about composition too
because
uh we're gonna dive into qixel bridge
here and pick some assets
that we can fill and populate our scene
with and i'll be asking you guys what
you want to see in the still life we'll
put it together and then we'll light it
um so definitely wherever you are
whatever program you're in
um
follow along because that's the best way
to learn is to just to just do it and
dive in so that's what we'll be doing
over the next couple hours here um but
yeah hey what's up everybody i set the
stream to low latency so hopefully we
can talk pretty uh
pretty consistently pretty quickly here
um
it said there might be some lag in the
stream or whatever some loss in quality
on the stream but let me know if that's
an issue
how's everybody doing you guys doing
right on uh on a saturday and by the way
guys i get this question all the time
what the heck is this glove for well
this glove is for my track pad i have a
wacom tablet down here and i use the pen
so it helps me glide across the tablet a
lot smoother
okay so here i'm gonna do
a little countdown
and when i say go you guys give me a
thumbs up ready three two one thumbs up
how how fast is that
dude your glove came an hour ago awesome
okay so that's about like eight seconds
that's not bad
that's not bad
sweet guys well thanks for joining um
we're going to dive in here i'm just
going to open up uh
pureref which is a program that one of
the mods on our server told me about
and um by the way if you're not part of
the server it's free the link's down
below and you can
um
you know basically use it to
join the weekly challenge that i host
every single week i'll be announcing the
winners of that weekly challenge and
it's also a place to um
meet other 3d artists
and share your work ask for questions
get some help it's a good time
so yeah this is pureref and what i'm
going to do is just drag and drop all of
these references
here
um let's see
yeah
and this will allow me to zoom in and
see
you know what i'm what i'm trying to go
for
there's a lot of good stuff in these you
know like this light i'm really loving
this window light on the back here this
one's fun too this is like kind of like
a little stage setup
but there
there's some some really nice lighting
setups here that i think we could really
use you know i like these candles here
so we'll probably get into some of that
maybe grab some grapes if we can find it
um a basket perhaps i don't want to
you know i don't want to make something
that looks too much like this like too
old school
and i also don't want to make something
that looks too much like
you know some like country living
magazine photo i want to do something in
between so that'll definitely be a
challenge for us i definitely like the
uh what is it called they're like the
churaskiro lighting
which you kind of see here there's a
very like soft light and there's a lot a
lot of darkness with mixed with the
light so it's very moody i love the
mcdonald's cups too i think that's great
so we'll be getting into
how to set that up you know this is a
good good example of the candle here
it's just lit from a candle
and
maybe some glasses in there for some
reflection maybe but we will
we'll see yeah i'm excited to dive into
this so again this program is called
puref it's really great it's free
and it's a great way to reference stuff
it's always on the top so no matter what
window i open
it'll always be on the top
yeah churro churro skiro
churro yeah churros girl
why is the christmas tree up well man
because it's almost christmas
and me and my fiance we don't get to see
each other really on christmas
so we like to get the tree up a little
early that way we can feel like we're
spending christmas together
um
so
before
we
jump into it guys um if you hadn't
noticed already this episode this stream
is sponsored by skillshare
and skillshare is
um
has been a sponsor
for these streams
once a month over the the entire course
of the year since i've been doing this
so definitely thanks to them they offer
a really really cool service if you guys
don't know what skillshare is at this
point you've been living under a rock
um
but basically it's an online learning
community
for creatives like you guys who are
looking to learn more and grow their
value and up their game no matter what
area you're trying to learn in so they
offer courses and classes
um over a wide range of skills so it
doesn't matter what you're into as long
as you can look it up on skillshare you
can learn it so it can be 3d it can be
3d lighting like we're talking about
right now but can also be like uh like
taxes
or um you know painting
or
interior design whatever you guys are
into skateboarding photography whatever
um and the classes are all bite-sized so
they're super small um you don't need to
spend hours and hours and hours like you
may do on the stream you can go and just
watch like a 5-10 minute little class
and move on to
the second part when you're done so let
me show you three classes that i'm that
i'm digging since we're talking about
lighting and since you guys are really
into blender they offer that exactly
this is of course here by stephen
pearson and it's how to model and light
and design a like an interior home setup
in blender
and it's a really popular course
it's 43 lessons for our course but you
can see how they're broken up into these
little bite-sized bits here
um
another one here by evan so this one
actually he gets into how to light like
a nighttime kind of a scene like you see
here
which is different from what we're doing
and i believe yep he's using maya
which some of you guys might use maya
i'm just is this is an example to show
you guys like um all the different kind
of
programs and tools that you can dig into
on skillshare
um and the last one the third one
is how to and this guy's this guy's
awesome patrick foley i've talked about
his work before um he's posted a lot on
skillshare
and he actually talks to you guys about
how to make your own hdri lighting setup
now i did a similar video on this
earlier in the year
but patrick foley goes over it as well
how to get that realistic lighting setup
with an hdri so he's going to walk you
through that process this one's only 30
minutes so nice and nice and short nice
and sweet
and as a skillshare member you guys get
unlimited access to regularly updated
premium content for less than 9.99 a
month for an annual subscription
i've been getting good at this i've been
doing this a lot
um so for the first thousand of you guys
who click the link below
um you guys get a free trial to
skillshare premium
so go check it out it helps me out
um you know they keep coming back and
they
um
allow me to tell you guys about
skillshare and it gives me a little
something extra for taking my time to do
these streams here so check it out i
promise you'll learn a lot
and it's a free trial so you can't lose
all right
so
it's time to jump in guys
it's time to dive in
to the lesson today and if you're just
joining us we are making
a uh a nice little renaissance set up
here we're gonna grab some fruit and
some vegetables from
qixel bridge
and we're gonna set it up so i'm gonna
ask you guys first off
how's everybody doing you guys doing
right let me address the chat here i
haven't done it in what since 10 minutes
since we started this thing
um yes i did shave
i did indeed nice and smooth
all right low wait low latency is so bad
would you guys agree
should i switch it back
um is the latency good with the thumbs
up or is the stream quality bad with the
thumbs down let me know
ah the stream keeps stopping
it says no it's fine looks perfectly
fine
um sodamonte if people
if enough people say it's bad enough
let me know here and i'll i'll switch it
up okay
all right we're looking good
we looking good yeah we ready for
christmas too we got the tree
in the back wrong side i don't know what
side i'm on
there's the tree yeah back there you
guys see it
alright so i'm going to ask y'all what
do you want to see in our
our little amalgamation of fruit and
vegetables and whatnot now i'm probably
not going to do some flowers i do like
the
you know the pumpkin and the bread and
all that good stuff with some candles
but specifically
what are you guys trying to see in this
setup i'm gonna leave it to you so
i got the vegetables page open on
quixote bridge under 3d assets
uh just start shouting some stuff out
if you at punisher me here in the chat
i'll be able to see that it is it is
vegetable related
and i'll be able to pull uh
pull whatever you guys want from here so
whatever you can see on the screen
let me know we'll start here
and we'll make our way downtown
all right we gotta have some grapes
we'll find some grapes alright we'll try
and find some grapes i see all on the
grapes
i don't think they have grapes here but
we'll figure it out all right
we will figure it out
an onion yes please
an onion
and a shallot or that's a garlic clove
we'll get the onion all right
bam let's download the onion
cucumber your favorite fruit okay done
pickles please in a jar pickles in a jar
all right yeah we got pickles we can do
pickles in a jar i'm down for that
carrots y'all like carrots let's do
carrots both carrots because why not
a gourd
a potato and a gourd
agreed
agreed
okay so we got potato one
and that is the weirdest looking pumpkin
i've ever seen in my life
a gourd is a pumpkin we need a pumpkin
so i'm gonna grab
just all the pumpkins right there
we got a potato
maybe we grab two potatoes
a big juicy mango all right we ain't on
fruit yet we're gonna get there all
right i promise
um i'm gonna throw in some ginger for me
because i love ginger i got my ginger a
kombucha right here
we ain't sponsored by gt's i wish we
were
but uh i'm a big fan i'm a big fan of
ginger i think it's great
rosemary ooh some herbs i don't know if
they have herbs up in here though i wish
they did
i'm gonna keep it simple we're gonna
stick to what's on the uh on the page
here
i had a random cube into the render i'm
down for that a little bit of that um
there's an example here where there's
just a random mcdonald's bag
which i thought is hilarious
so maybe we can do something like that
i'll i'll uh
we'll get there we'll get there we're
not there yet
but yeah garlic somebody said garlic i'm
down for garlic i love garlic
um quick how expensive is bridge it's
not that expensive actually qixel is a
service based um
company so it's about 20 bucks a month
and they um
yeah you you get mixer and bridge and
access to all of their assets and
everything
it for me is
i can't live without it they've done a
really good job
they've done a fantastic job
i'd say it's definitely well worth it if
you're creating enough stuff they make
it really easy transferred into your
program
yeah it's great it's the best all right
let's move on let's go to fruit
and let's get into some fruit alright
what do you guys want to see
in our amalgamation here
and yeah it is free and unreal
quixl
assets are free for unreal which is
freaking awesome
oh what a sign is cliff what up cliff
heck yeah
i'm excited for that t2 movie night very
excited for that that's coming up soon
yeah cliff we're making a uh
we're making like a a nice renaissance
style set up here
um
if you got blender open son
you might as well open it up our unity
maybe we can get some get some of this
stuff going could be fun
all right what fruits what fruits
watermelon and tomato
am i wearing vessies no i'm not wearing
bessies at the moment they're in the
closet
but they are legit comfy shoes
okay
someone said an apple
apples pack done
i like bananas i'm gonna grab a banana
all right that's just because all right
it's quick so free quicksilver's free
for unreal engine
and maybe for other things but um if
you're using for anything else it's 20
bucks a month
what's up tila
all right a mango
a mango
where are you this is gonna be
embarrassing but i don't know okay
there's a mango here we go
pineapples are the best yeah pineapples
are pretty great
we can just do like a bunch of discarded
stumps
in the background
pears are legit so we're gonna think
about shapes too you know
oh there's your gourd
man there's gonna be a lot how are we
gonna how are we gonna get all this
stuff
someone said a watermelon
a lemon or just a straight up lemon all
right okay
i got you on the watermelon i got you on
the
watermelon
all right um let's
i'm just gonna grab this meat right here
because that's gonna be nice
baked goods all right now here's where
it goes down we got cookies we got bread
we got loafs we got buns
um we got
pastries and christian
thank you for the kombucha money i
appreciate it every single week you hook
me up with kombucha appreciate it man
they are certainly helpful on the stream
because i talk straight for three hours
and my throat gets all sore so i'm gonna
get something to drink you know what i
mean
okay guys we're on baked goods what do
you all want what are you feeling
we're gonna get the grapes don't worry
we'll get the grapes
some way somehow we'll get the grapes
all right we'll get some subsurface
through the grapes
but what bread are you guys feeling
right now
a cinnamon roll
down for cinnamon roll
it's like a curly bun
i gotta get this loaf of bread here
maybe this guy right here boom
here's another
a cardamom bun i've never even heard of
one of those
this guy looks good
that looks delicious
some grainy bread okay some good texture
like this guy
i like this guy right here
or the black bread
yeah
okay all right i think we have enough
except for
like vases and stuff we need a bunch of
vases don't we
so we'll go to 3d assets
interior
um
hmm
decoration
and we want
oh candle holders could work bowls could
work
let's grab some bowls
hmm
wooden bowl i like that that one's nice
we need a large bowl
maybe this
guy oh these are interesting
so we just want variety here
but i do like this wood style
i think that's really nice
now i may not use everything
but we'll do our best candle holders
an old one yes
absolutely
hmm
i mean that old one's pretty much the
one you know
get a couple of those
maybe this one
and that's a lot of stuff to download so
good thing i got fiber at the new place
we can download quickly grapes all right
y'all
let's see i don't think quixil has
grapes
they have grapevines
but it might be something that we
download from turbosquid or cg trader
so
let me see here this is this this is
crucial the grapes are crucial
so i'm gonna go
let's see if we can do
[Music]
let me start this download
while we look for some grapes all right
so i'm gonna go to my favorites
and
it looks like we have 4k versions of
everything
[Music]
so let's download
all this stuff
it's going to do its thing
hopefully we don't break the stream here
all right now let's look for some grapes
all right
i just googled grapes uh
let's go to turbo squid
or even better let's go to free3d.com
and let's see
if we can find some grapes
20 bucks
nah
those are some ugly
grapes all right let's try turbo squid
we've got
rapes and we'll search price
free grapes what kind of free grapes do
we have
79
nope
a great collection um okay we're talking
fbx
hmm
those grapes look really low
low poly there um
let's see if we can't find
some cheaper grapes 10 bucks
what do we got for 10 bucks
oh wow okay oh actually guys what are we
what are we doing
polygon
i know you have grapes andrew price
models
food
fruits and veggies
and blueberries
we have blueberries we have cherries and
we have
blackberries but we do not
have grapes
dang it
wait
god those are limes
crap
pomegranates
but no grapes
back at it again all right cgtrader.com
i hope this is entertaining for y'all
i hope this isn't boring at all right
now
um
freaking grapes
okay
22 grapes those look like some good
grapes nine dollar grapes okay this is
what uh this is what's up right here
these these grapes it's nine dollars
it's affordable
i think we can do that
i think we can make that happen
bam
nine dollar grapes all right
i'm gonna do this over here so y'all
don't steal my credit card information
all right
looks like most of this stuff is already
downloaded fantastic
let's um
let's add the grapes to the cart over
here
and i'm going to start transferring all
this stuff into c4d so
i'm just going to straight up click this
export 15 assets button
and it's going to go
start exporting up top
and in c4d you'll start to see the stuff
load in
while i
proceed to checkout
on cg trader
[Music]
all right
where is my credit card
credit card is not with me
okay um
maybe paypal let's do paypal
all right momentarily guys momentarily
we're gonna start adding everything in
so
if we zoom away in
we can see
that we have a lot of stuff a lot of
fruits and veggies
so let's go ahead and
break this
stuff up and lay out all the stuff we
have okay those are some massive apples
those are huge
so we got our fruit over here
and we'll just organize everything
there's our baked goods over here
let me hide this plane for a second
all right we got our grapes
let's download these guys
they got the fbx i didn't even check
thank goodness
um
let's do vfx materials 3d models
and a cg
trader bam
and let's merge it
and see if we can't get these grapes up
in here um 3d models
c
g where are you trader bam
we got some grapes
awesome you all got your grapes up in
here
so we'll put that with the fruit
um we got another bowl throw that over
here
veggies
what is that a carrot
veggies
veggies and we want that pickle in the
jar
so we might model a glass jar
that's like veggies all this stuff is
veggies
pickle lots of vegetables
oh what about our pumpkins
i thought we had pumpkins too um
[Music]
let me go back to bridge and make sure
we got our pumpkins
oh there's a there's a number of stuff
we didn't get all right let's get the
garlic
and some pumpkins
can i turn up the mic audio
hmm
um let's see
let us see
it's maxed out for me here maybe
advanced settings
all right mic
volume
how's that is that any better
i think they got a little louder
i can just talk louder too
all right let's get our potatoes make
sure
we got everything here
and in fruits i feel like there's a
couple more fruits i like the banana i
know that we wanted that banana
and the mango the juicy mango and some
eaten apples
all right
so now we download it and we start
building out our scene now we need to
figure out what
um
kind of style we want to go for i really
like this window light on the back wall
i think that looks really nice it's lit
it's like a nice daylight look
um but this is cool too the way it has
like a nice little like
arch in a recess
that way it allows the light to be a bit
more dynamic so
we'll have to figure that one out um the
burlap sack is nice
i like that look
this is
this is quite the spread here we got
nuts down here with some fruits and
some pumpkins and baskets and whatnot
you got your grapes
wow that's quite the quite the spread
quite the spread indeed
all right let's check bridge and
get the rest of our stuff so we can
start building
all right we need these guys
and all this bread yeah we had this
bread too
and the ham and the roll and the lemon i
knew we had more stuff
the mango the banana
the garlic
some pumpkins
i think we're good with that
let's download those
unless they're already no they're
already downloaded
i think
some of them are
so
all right well that goes
how
is everybody doing um
private jell-o thank you for the great
money
i appreciate you man
thank you so much that's that's awesome
um and what is the image reference
software it's called pure ref
p-u-r-e-r-e-f
pure ref i love it um it's a fantastic
piece of software
good times am i out
no i'm not out
that's a close one
one two
boom boom
all right just download the rest of
everything
no i'm well i'm very well
um last over the last month we did that
uh
that render challenge the parallel
dimensions render challenge and it
turned out so well i couldn't be
happier with all the amazing results and
how well the video did
it's almost 50 000 views right now which
is incredible
um it's really nice to have a video pop
off and
and especially since it's showing off
your guys's work
um
yeah it's just amazing casey put
together an original score for it and
it's just going through all the best
stuff so if you guys haven't seen this
already definitely check it out it's on
my channel
really good times amazing absolutely
incredible
um so that was good that was really fun
to be able to put that together and and
have it pay off so well
um how else am i doing i'm modeling
at corridor for our functional
filmmaking class
um i'm doing a vfx class on how to make
things look realistic i modeled this
camera from scratch
over the last two days and either monday
or tuesday i'll be texting it and
i'll be posting some stuff on instagram
with my results and everything and then
the functional filmmaking class is
talking you guys through like
what to keep your eye out for when
you're trying to create something real
so i'm i'm excited for that very excited
for that
all right now let's export all these
assets here i think everything's
downloaded at this point
maybe except for one
still waiting on the cornbread
and we'll bring everything in i'm just
ready to get going now let me ask you
guys this do you want me to download all
this stuff beforehand or do you enjoy
watching me download stuff
i couldn't imagine how this is fun um
i feel like i should do this
when i'm not streaming but hey this the
whole process you guys get to see the
whole thing
shawnee this will be up yeah don't worry
about it man if you gotta run all good
this will be up after the fact
but we'll miss you we enjoy doing it
live together
ronan i'm glad i'm glad man i'm glad
it's uh
you're enjoying it okay let's download
what we can all right
let's get all of this good stuff
um i think we got that one
we might have some duplicates but that's
a-okay we can handle that later
the pumpkins i know we need
and let's down no export we're gonna
export everything
download live always
i'm glad you guys enjoy it
max it says hey do you use any other
software for your main work or just c4d
as the main package
sorry if you're english you're not a
native speaker i'd say your english is
great i wouldn't have noticed if you
didn't say that
um
so yeah cinema4d is my go-to for 3d
after effects is my go-to for
compositing davinci was my go-to for
editing until it wouldn't open for me
i tried everything and it wouldn't open
it just kept crashing so i had to switch
back to premiere for the parallel
dimensions render montage
with every intention of going back to da
vinci i really like it i do like da
vinci it's free too
i use photoshop a lot
i'm actually doing a
you guys will be excited about this i'm
doing a surface imperfection video which
some of you probably know about already
um so i've been creating a lot of my own
surface imperfections
um and i use photoshop for that so let
me show you guys real quick
um we got all of this stuff here
fingerprints dust grain
scratches water spots
everything to make your model look real
to make your renders look real and then
i'm doing like smudges and stuff on
glass like this
very excited to show you guys my process
the video is going to talk about how to
make these yourself
and then i'm going to talk about how to
implement them into your renders
and then i'm going to sell pack
basically at the end of the video
um you know all the the imperfections
that i made
i'll be able uh i'll offer to you guys
for i don't know how much yet
but it's gonna be a really fun pack i
look forward to it and just the video
alone it's gonna show you guys how to do
it
um
it's really fun it's really really
really fun i'm quite addicted to it
so
that's a good time i don't know where i
was going with that
um
who knows
who knows
oh yeah photoshop i was using photoshop
great fantastic
those are the main ones
yeah those are my main ones for sure
all right back into cinema
go ahead and save save save save i'm
saving iterations this is what chris
schmidt over at rocket lasso does he
saves iterations so i got one a one b
one c one d
um and it allows you
the ability to go back and change things
if you want to change things
so you never lose work
all right we got bread over here
i just want to organize all of our stuff
get all of our ass outs assets out in
front of us
um and then we can create efficiently
technique no these are these are veggies
this is a fruit
fruit goes here
what is that okay that's baked goods
baked
goods veggies veggies and a lemon
and that looks to me like
everything
awesome
um
y'all are awesome
alex bonner's thank you needs a kitchen
knife stuck into the table
ooh
ooh
let's see let's see what they have let's
see what bridge has real quick
infero thank you for the super chat both
of you guys really appreciate it
favorite said oh i just noticed you made
the cardboard warfare i remember
watching like 10 years ago thanks for
the nostalgia absolutely man yeah
carbon warfare man it's a good time i
want to do cardboard fair 3 and have it
be sci-fi i look forward to it right now
there's no time you know i'm working
full-time at corridor so
um maybe sometime in the future we'll
see i don't know maybe i'll just chip
away at it
day by day month by month until it's
done at the end of like two years or
something
but uh yeah man i'm glad you i'm glad
you went on that little nostalgia trip
that's great
yay aldon you just installed bridge
congratulations
um
tila
tila tila tila i apologize
do i need to scroll up
i do need to scroll up tila thank you so
much
and you're not being rude i appreciate
it i don't want to miss any any super
chats so thank you so much
he says these streams have been the best
content of 2020. keep up the good work
um thank you tila
a whole bunch man i appreciate you
and i hope that all you guys are
learning something and it means a lot
you know this the small like little tips
and everything it does mean a lot to me
um
because this is this is a freaking blast
i love doing this it's work though it's
hard work certainly
um because i do the full time at
corridor
and then saturday you know i do this as
well
um
but
anyway i digress thank you tila for the
super chat sorry for missing
uh
that and thank you for the reminder
you're not rude at all
absolutely we all gotta be recognized
for that kind of stuff i appreciate it
okay
so
is it time is it finally time that we
start building this out now what do we
want to build this out on do we want to
build it out onto a table like what's
our
what's our setup what's our stage going
to be like we could go with something
like this where it's just a cloth
on the table
um
it's so easy for me to get sidetracked
and distracted
man it's difficult it's difficult but
hey we're gonna focus we're focusing now
all right we're gonna get that knife on
the table hopefully if i remember
remind me
okay
now this is the easiest way we go with
something like this
this is just a basic psych um kind of
backdrop a psych is basically a curved
wall so you have uh you know like a like
a green screen psych or any like studio
or
photography psych it's like a gray
and then it ramps up into the background
so it looks like an endless background
that's how they get that effect
and i know grayscale gorilla
has
some stuff like that
i don't know if i have installed
currently but
let's keep going so this is like a
concrete marble slab that falls off into
the background
with a nice like textured wall back here
i like that look i think it's nice
i definitely want to go for something
simple i don't do anything too crazy
but again i do like this
this idea down here where it's like an
alcove that way you have dark and light
together and i like the idea of doing
something vertical rather than
horizontal
because i want to be able to post this
on instagram and instagram's all about
that vertical those vertical images
so
maybe something like this
where it stands up taller in the
background
with this like with this alcove idea
i like the alcove idea so let me go on
bridge and see if we can find any like
architectural arc
architectural
architectural role
architecture architectural
um like assets you know what i'm trying
to say
that's like when you try to say i edited
i edited
it can you be honest it could be a
difficult word right all right let's um
3d assets
props interior industrial historical
food building
um
window wall trim stair roof
railing pillar maybe
combined
hmm
interesting
um
yeah building
let's just go through everything see we
can find walls
or maybe it's in
3d assets
historical
roman
maybe there's something in here that
could work for us
hmm
no
maybe a medieval setup
i'm looking for something that
might
maybe this
but it looks a little low poly to me
um pharaoh my goodness
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for that super chat that is very very
kind and generous of you
pharaoh says i really do appreciate the
stuff you make independently and with
corridor so this is the least i could do
i would love to say
uh to stay or stay around but me and the
boys are gonna go for a range day see
you later dog thank you so much pharaoh
appreciate you enjoy the range day
get that trigger discipline locked down
and uh watch that trigger squeeze you
know you gotta pull back straight back
you know you get that it'll dip left if
you get the trigger finger wrong
shooting shooting is difficult shooting
is very difficult especially doing
pistols
um enjoy thank you so much
have a good one be safe
all right
all right indeed you guys are awesome
thank you so much
so
maybe we just modeled this ourselves
this kind of set up here
it looks pretty
simple to do
um
let's
try and give it a shot okay
so here's what we'll do i'm gonna i'm
gonna reference this and just build this
out all right
now to me this looks like
a cube
something like this mixed with um a
cylinder
and the cylinder is going to be beveled
and we're going to cut out
with a bull
a boolean
right in here so i'll take the cylinder
and i want to give it um
a fillet a fillet
and we'll just say like 10 segments by
uh one foot
maybe we'll go all the way yeah we'll go
we'll go all the way so it maxes out
right there
which looks very similar to this right
here the shape that you're seeing is
this right here okay
so let's maybe extend the cube out and
up perhaps
because this also has an effect on our
lighting
you don't want to limit it to
just
what you're seeing in the camera
the light of your scene is affected by
things outside of the camera as well so
we again we can adjust this i'm not
going to make these editable
um quite yet so
the way i remember this it's always a
minus b for boolean stuff right so the
cube is our a
it's our cube which is a
minus b
equals
this right here okay so i'll select both
of them by holding shift and in cinema
if you hold ctrl and alt
down you can let go on eventually when i
find it you can let go on bull and it'll
just be in there and then there you go
it's cut out and it's looking good let's
give the cylinder a couple more um
segments here so rotational segments why
not let's go 100.
if i hit nb
you know we're seeing something there we
go to our bowl objects hide new edges
that's by default
in
updated versions of cinema
and now it looks like there's this like
ground plane here
which to me looks like just a spline
with an extrude on it so i'm gonna go
into top view
and
let's find what we just made
all right
now to me it looks like they're doing
something like this let's bring the
circle and make a circle spline
and based off the reference
it's doing something like that and then
it's combined with a
rectangle spline
that we can move
actually here here's a tip
if you want to spawn the rectangle
spline on the circle spline hold ctrl
and it'll spawn there
it's a very easy and fast way to do that
tom moore
thank you sir for the super chat you
guys are on a roll today thank you so
much your stream is the best part of the
week at the moment thank you thank you
so much tom um really appreciate you man
i'm very very glad that you're learning
something i'm glad that i can make this
fun for you all so
you guys are the best you guys are the
best thank you thank you
all right so
continuing on let's just let's just burn
through it
it's something like this again based off
the reference i'm looking at this
reference here i'm asking myself
does this um horizontal like floor piece
is it cutting off the sphere halfway
back which would be like this halfway
back
or is it a little closer to the front
and to me it looks like it's a little
closer to the front so i think that's
what it's going to look like
something like that okay so that's
that's the shape we want to draw
now i don't know if this works but if i
take both of these and i throw it into
an extrude
is it going to give me
no it looks like it's just going to give
me one but maybe if i take both of them
and i connect plus delete
it'll give me both
the geometry isn't the best
geometry is certainly not the
best
i don't know if that matters
currently
but
if it does i'll go back and change it
okay
um that looks like a
3.5 inch slab to me so i'll bring that
down and just sit it right there so
that's kind of
what we're looking at and then finally
we can do our trim
this nice trim that goes around here so
i think the best way to do the trim
what would be the best way to do this
trim um it looks like it looks to me
like a cube being wrapped around
and then
a
it could be another cube just kind of
adjusted here
on the side
hmm how would i do that
if i baked everything down and cut some
edge loops i could probably
pull that out let's give it a shot i'm
going to duplicate my bool first i'm
going to save a new iteration
let's bake it down
hide the new one
let's
connect all these
objects and delete
everything else connect objects plus
delete so now we just have
this cube here
and let's hit kl
go to line mode
and it's not allowing us so we need to
use the knife tool kk is the shortcut
so let me go into side view
and see if we can't chop some edges here
it's right before it starts to turn up
here so i'm going to go
let's um let's hide all these
assets
and let's select
our
um let's select our i don't know
architecture did i spill it who knows
holding shift will keep it straight
i'll cut one line
and
let's cut
two more holding shift
to make those cuts
and let's see if that works i don't know
if the geometry is going to be all that
great but
we'll see let's select all of that ul
for
loop selection
now since our geometry is a little janky
it might not okay here's what i have to
do i have to go back because it didn't
go all the way around i need to make
sure in the line cut options
let's see visible only is unchecked that
way
we're able to cut through everything
like a laser
and you can always move these points
once we cut them but
now you can see they go all the way
around
our cube and let me hide the grid for
you all so you can see what's happening
cool so now when you hit ul and you do
your loop cut
or your loop selection
it'll at least get
everything around the cube
and it's because of the way the geometry
works with the boolean it's not the best
we gotta shift click the rest of that so
we get all of it right hit d for extrude
that's something i learned on the stream
here i thought you had to hit md
or no md it was i don't even remember
the old shortcut because d is the best
one
preserve groups we'll uncheck it
um create caps
so we'll need to bridge that gap here
we'll need to bridge this so
we'll uncheck
preserve groups
bring this out
maybe about that much right there
and then let's go ahead and bridge i
think it's mb
go into edge mode
and i'm just bridging this gap right
here
md is to
close polygon hole which you should get
here
but it's not letting us
let's maybe delete
these
faces mb for bridge tool in edge mode
click and drag click and drag
md
to close polygon hole and it's not
really letting us maybe the bridge tool
mb will work
seems to do a good job
now i wonder if bevel would have worked
for this
maybe i'm gonna hit ul
polygon mode
um
and it's not letting us do a loop
selection for some reason
because the geometry is all janky so
we'll go into side view
and let's go ahead and grab
go to point mode i'm gonna hit 0 for the
box selection tool
let's grab those
ctrl shift z to undo camera movements
holding down control to deselect those
still holding ctrl click the polygon
mode oh wow
it's just jank city
i'm gonna undo all that
because i don't think that's the answer
so this is what it takes y'all this is
trial and error try to figure out the
best way to do something
sometimes it's not the easiest
okay
so
let's figure this out
obliviousness
i appreciate you thank you very much
i appreciate it man and yeah
it wasn't the right way
it wasn't the right way
i think maybe the best way to do this is
to just have some detached because my
geometry is screwed all right my
geometry is screwed because i use the
bulling
and it just kind of sucks when you do
that all right so i think the best way
to do this
is to maybe just use like a bend
or something or honestly
i'm gonna try this i'm gonna try this
i'm gonna take the original cylinder we
used
so it's sitting right here okay
i'm gonna make it editable
kl
for line cut
let's make it let's optimize it uo
um
why is it not working
there we go
all right so let's make some cuts i'm
gonna just try and make a cut
right here and
i'll make a cut right here
and i want to take
these bits right here and hit
u p that's going to break up
up
let's see where are you
u and p split it's split so it's
breaking off just those polygons let's
hide that cylinder
and now we have these guys right in here
so this
is already lined up perfectly with the
wall
so i'll take this
and we'll use this
and let's go ahead and
hit d and extrude it in
just like that we'll have to flip the
normals so ctrl a to select all and then
weird why am i in this double situation
um maybe it's my
oh because they're coming in they're
like
crashing into each other um
preserve groups
there we go preserve groups does it
sweet so now we have the correct
geometry
and we should
create caps that way it makes a solid
object ctrl a to select it all you are
to flip normals
um all right from here what i'll
probably do is
grab
both of these polygons and both of these
polygons hit d
and extrude them
now they're obviously going to go off
in
a weird direction
but
imma just bring them back
correct the course
let's hide
let's hide our
bull object
to see if we can make better sense of
this down here so i think
the reason that wasn't working is
because the edges
or the faces weren't selected
awesome so we'll bring those four
okay so now the reason that's not
working is because our access mode is
enabled which is this button right here
so you can either click it or hit l
and we'll be able to move those forward
and let's bring our bull back in
to line it up
not bad
not bad at all
and then from here
i'm actually going to delete
all of this stuff so
i'm going to select everything
[Music]
and then just hit u y which is gross
selection
a few times and that should wrap around
and get everything
so that's that and then we just need to
shift-click and get all this stuff over
here
delete and this is when you would bridge
so mb
in edge mode
gets you the bridge
and we need to make this a right angle
which i don't know if there is
a better way to do this i'm sure there
is but what i'm going to do is grab
these edges
holding shift those edges
these guys and finally these guys and
we'll go into top view
we'll zoom way in
to see if it lines up
and i will actually go into
this view here and i'll zoom in
to the gizmo
to have full control over it
and then you can see how we have like
it's very sensitive
or no i'm sorry it's the opposite
we have a lot of control over i'm
looking at i'm looking right here
trying to get that line
that should do it
so now it will appear at least to be
straight and i'll save a new iteration
there you go so now we have that in
there which is this bottom piece the top
piece is easy we just
pull these in a bit and we can bevel it
so
let me grab
in edge mode
ul for loop selection
plus
this guy
and this guy and i'm gonna go ahead and
scale them
in
and move them
up
oh no
let's
save the moving part let's scale those
in a little bit more
and then i'm going to do ul in polygon
mode
and i want to deselect those polygons
down below so i'll go into front mode
hit zero for rectangular selection
holding control will deselect those guys
and then now we just need to deselect
these ones here
and select
this top face here and here so now we
can move these up
just like that
and
these edges
here and here need to come out
like that
and they can scale out a little bit
something like that so now you have this
like nice shelf
and then we're going to bevel all right
it all comes down to the bevel
um
let's do
a bevel modifier that's my favorite so
i'm going to hold shift
and drop the bevel modifier inside it
looks like but
um
let's do
0.1 inches to see what's going on it
looks like there's some
geometrical
screw-ups
in here so maybe the cylinder
if we select all of that and we hit uo
and optimize it does that help okay it
doesn't help
um
[Music]
looks like there's a face
in here that needs to go
let me uh
let me hide this bull object
oh this is some funkiness over here
so these guys maybe i'll take this
and scale it
i'm gonna hide my sky i think i'm
selecting what am i selecting
oh it's the bevel modifier okay
weird
i don't know why that's not working
they should be able to scale together
oh wow that's why i think i'm in this
weird mode
yes you can zero out the z
so that might be doing something
just straighten that up i'm just kind of
like cleaning up the geometry a little
bit
and that's one thing i'm not good with
like i i can i can get my way around
modeling but i'm not the best
and let's
try the bevel modifier again
so we're still getting this like rogue
little piece which might be
[Music]
the
the bridge tool how we did the bridge
tool
you also might not be able to see it
when we do it for real um let's
crank the angle threshold
oh it's because they're not
there's like a face in there
that it's getting that inside piece
so to fix that we gotta do some surgery
um
let's see i'm gonna make a cut here an
incision point
and delete that
and
delete these points
and bridge this mb
in edge mode
and let's see if that
fixed it
it did
wonderful
tila
thank you for the for the hydration
warning
it's great
thank you thank you
all right we got some water take a
little water break
so this is what we're doing we're doing
the little wrapping here on
this alcove and then we start placing
all of our stuff
and that's when it gets really fun
we start placing and lighting we're
doing the we're doing the grunt worker
now
setting the stage for
the creative that's about to go down
why does my octane always say zero days
left
you know i don't know
i have no idea
i think it's because um
i get cinema 4d and octane
from the companies from both companies
so i might be getting some version of it
where it just says zero days left or
something and it's just like a perpetual
forever kind of a thing who knows
yeah i've used maya victor i've used
maya for three months i learned maya and
i decided that it was a little bit much
for me
and uh i really liked the way
cinema 4d felt
um it feels fun it feels like a
playground you know why i felt
too much like a like an office you know
because that's what you know uh
the studios use they use maya it's
because
it's easy to
as easy to use as a team
which is why they do it all right kl
knife cut boom make the incision point
ul loop selection delete it
those are the issue these two guys one
two delete them m b
that's your shortcut
in edge mode you wanna work the bridge
tool
and get that bridge tool going
yeah
you just gotta yeah get it
yeah
girl all right nice
and when we click off
things are look oh all right we forgot
the bottom right
m
b
bridge tool
bridge maintenance
maintenance the bridge mb
maintenance bridge
that's what that is for okay um let's
bring back the boo
[Music]
and now we have something let's render
it for once before we do that let's set
our aspect ratio i want to do
i want to do
what is it
if the width is
[Music]
600
no no the width is
2 000 the height should be 3 000
so that's 2 by 3
i think that's correct or is it three
thousand hold on hold on three thousand
by forty five hundred
i think that's the same thing
save an iteration render your scene
and let's see what we get
and i think it's going to take a minute
just because we have all these like
fruits and vegetables chilling off to
the side
but here we go
let's lock it
and let's set it to point one
0.125
there we go
so this is our scene
here all right we can get right up in
here
something like that and i'll probably
shoot this on a
i think a 35 is too wide maybe let's
let's try a
let's try a 50.
back out just a little bit
and let's stand
the cylinder
up
just a bit
something like that
will be nice so this is our
the stage that we have set for our scene
here
i want to get this looking really nice
let me i want to flatten this out a
little bit more so i'll do an 80.
and you can see that when you
your lines get straighter
when you shoot with a longer focal
length so if i'm shooting like on a 15
it's gonna make everything
really stretched out
and your lines won't be straight
they're gonna be really crazy
but if you shoot on a 200
it's almost gonna look
like some cad style modeling where
everything is very straight so i'm gonna
split the difference you know i like the
80 i think it's good
and based off our reference i think it's
similar
you know
so i will line this up right in here
and i just want to confirm
that this aspect ratio is correct so
what i do is i will check my
film photography or the aspect ratio of
like say my uh
my dslr it's the same i think it's two
to three
i'm pretty sure it's two to three aspect
ratio
let's double check this real quick
um pictures
photography
2304
30 72 2304
30 72
2304
30
72
and if we lock the aspect ratio
600 by 800
all right
i wonder if i had that right huh
anyway we can always change it later you
know
but let's see if we can't get that nice
lighting going so i'm what i'm gonna do
is
black out the entire room and the way
i'm gonna do that is
basically make an hdri environment for
octane it's a octane sky
so i don't need any hdri
i just need to set it to a color and
zero it out
so now it's lighting
this with just a black a black globe
where we see nothing okay
um
so what i'll want to do
is light it with basically a window so
i'm going to make a soft box just like a
light
an area light come off to the side here
and
see what we can get here if we hop into
camera view and we look at this
and we try and match this kind of
lighting setup very soft light i love it
the first thing i'm going to do is turn
on the intensity it's too much
and i'm going to go into my octane
camera settings
and let me just organize this a little
bit for y'all and in fact let me pop
this out
and get it going right here
here we go
so my octane camera tag i'm going to go
to camera imager and i'm going to turn
up the highlight compression and if you
notice on the left
it's going to save those highlights it's
not going to clip out like it does it's
really going to make it nice and soft
very similar to our reference
um
i feel like
we can go a little higher on our arch
piece
something like that
and i think we can come a little lower
on this
something like that cool
now to get this light
even softer
we
can just make it larger
and then turn down the intensity so in
my octane live viewer if i go to
[Music]
options
and uncheck the check camera option
which is very confusing i can hop out of
my camera in the viewport
and adjust this light and my
dialog or my live viewer will actually
update
so we want the softest light we can get
if i make this thing if i stand it up
taller
it's gonna it's gonna get us more light
but i don't want too much you know
i think i need to
again based off the reference it's
really hitting here
and here and it's not really hitting
this edge so i think i need to bring the
light up
and tilt it down just a bit
and it almost looks like it's coming
from like
from like up here or something
and we can mess with this we can always
mess with this
to try and get that look
that we want and we can use flags like
we can use um like a say a plane
so i can hold ctrl and spawn a plane
right on the light there
and i'll scale that down
and you know you ever seen like the barn
doors on lights that's what this is for
so if i rotate this and pretend like
this is a barn door
on the light and i'll
let's just say i'm i i make it editable
let's go to the plane
and set the
yeah that's a zero and make it editable
and i want the
axis to be on the far side like this
let me bring it over
and then this can act as like a barn
door
that blocks the light
from maybe hitting this wall here
and i can scale it up
until it really
really blocks the light
and you have to position this
carefully
you see it's blocking the light there
oh now here's the issue here's the issue
it's because it's white you need to set
it to a black material so i'm going to
make a diffuse material apply it and
then set it to zero zero zero
so it goes black that way it's not
bouncing any light which you're gonna
get if you're in path tracing mode
all right so i'm going to keep messing
with this
there we go so now it's really starting
to block the light
from that side
and then we could take the whole thing
if i put that into the light and then we
rotate it
that's a bit much
and we can use
different lights to really
work
work it in there i can also hit the
bottom too so if i want to duplicate
this plane
get it down here
right in the middle and then rotate it
90 degrees
and it's going to block the light from
the bottom
from down here to really
you know try and get that pull of light
right there in the middle
and let's really block the light there
and let's really block the light down
here
and then let's turn up the brightness
of this light
and when we throw a texture
like a marble stone texture on this it's
going to look really really nice
all right
so we can hide the
light visibility from the camera
if we need to we can also
hide it all from the viewport we just
know it's there
but let's go ahead and start placing
some of our objects now because i think
we're at that point so
it's about time huh
desert line what am i doing with those
lights
well there's only one light
in the scene
this light here is just an area light
it's a large area light so it's a large
source of light such as like this window
behind me a large source of light
pouring into the room if i make it a
small little itsy bitsy light and i turn
it up turn the brightness up a lot
the shadows are going to be a lot
harsher
you can see how harsh those shadows are
there that's because the light is small
but if the lights big
the shadows will be
softer so the bigger the light the
softer the shadows
now
what i'm doing
sorry what i'm doing with
these flags
is i'm blocking the light
so i don't want the light to you know
say light up certain parts of the image
so i'm blocking the light with those
planes you can see the difference that's
without the flags and this is with the
flags
and those are blocking the light from
certain areas and that's allowing me to
shape the image and shape the light of
this scene
and have full control over the scene
now another thing we do here is
in the post processing or i'm sorry
camera imager let's add a
vignette so i'll crank the vignette up
it's not going to update because we need
to make sure we check check camera
and we hop into the camera and i'm
actually going to put a lut on here so
let's get the vignette up
like that
awesome and then let's go ahead i like
portra 800
is really nice
uncheck neutral response that way we
keep the color from the lut
and you're not really going to notice
too much because we're just dealing with
white right here okay um
you know if i gave it a glossy
a glossy uh material
it's gonna it's actually gonna bounce
light
even more intensely
we can do like uh east's linear what is
that
what's that gonna look like
ah interesting so none of the lighting
options we mess with are going to take
effect because we're in aces here
this is just the raw data
that you get from the render but um i
like
a little bit of color correction in here
so
i think hdr tone map i still don't know
the
aces workflow that's something i really
need to dive into
but i'm gonna turn down the exposure
[Music]
or maybe it's the gamma yeah the gamma
should go to one
that gets you a bit more of a realistic
look but let's start placing stuff so
options uncheck the check camera option
so we can
hop out of our camera and start bringing
in some of these goodies all right i'm
going to grab all of these
alt g and i'm just going to call this
fruit
and veggies
all right
um ed you make a good point
i assume painters didn't have lights it
would have to be a window light so maybe
you should just poke a hole in a plane
for your lighting that's not a bad idea
i mean it's very similar to what i'm
doing right now i'm recreating that so
i have a black environment
i'm using an octane sky with just a
color it's black the lights are off and
then you have a light shaped like a
window bringing light into the room is
essentially what i'm going for now we
could go the extra mile and we could
duplicate the plane here
and make like slats which i think will
be really nice if we have any glass in
our scene or any like very reflective
fruit
um
so we can
scale these down
to give
oh that doesn't work
to block the light
oh that's all jacked up
well how did that happen
what on earth
all right that's good enough i think
yeah there we go so now from here i can
just
what the heck
control
holding down shift
11 point whatever
11 point whatever
and i'm just going down the same
amount every time
and you can make a window basically
and maybe that's too many maybe we
delete every other one
and give it the uh
the middle piece holding ctrl will
duplicate it holding shift snap it
and you get that like
middle piece there
so that that could be your window and
you'll see that in the reflection
so if i put a
let's grab one of our veggies
so what do we want to start with there's
a ham
chilling wow we got a lot of stuff here
and i can turn the light off in the
viewport
enable uh in order to see all this stuff
better
now if we just straight up drop a
pumpkin
oh here's here's another tip i want to
have all of these veggies and fruits
sitting on the ground
okay
and i want to be able to drag them in
and out easily
so to do that
i'm going to select everything here i'm
going to select all of these assets i'm
going to bring let's yeah the grapes are
fine
the apple pack the apples can come out
unleash the apples all right great
i'm going to select everything
there i'm going to go to the
axis center tool which i've actually had
a button up here for that
and i'm going to drag the y all the way
down
hit execute and you should have the y
axis
and all the gizmos for every one of
these little bits be at the bottom of
this fruit so you can see that it's
gizmos at the very bottom
that's because i slid the y slider all
the way down to negative 100. same for
all this bread
that's all at zero so now with all those
guys selected i can hit
reset psr
and that brings everything to the middle
to zero zero
and here's another thing i want to do
actually is
reset my camera and this architecture so
i'm going to let me just clean things up
so we can work quickly
this is my arch
this is also arch this is more arch trim
the cylinder can go away the extrude
will be my floor
all right so that is
my
architecture
i have a spell it who knows
deja vu all right um
now
i want to do the same i want to put
this at zero so actually i'm going to
hit l to enable the axis mode
and i want to get this gizmo sitting
just on top
of this marble which will soon be marble
countertop
right there
i think that's correct
yep
so now let's grab and let's put the
camera inside of the architecture
because
we want to move the camera with the
architecture because of the way we set
our angle up and then i'll zero it out
so position
oh
make sure you uncheck gizmo mode there
you go
we can pull the camera out
and now we have our fruits and veggies
we should be able to
move those guys out
so they're all sitting on the ground
zero
so that's our zero zero right there
and architecture
we can pull this out so that's the
center point
then we zero it out again
so anytime we spawn something if we want
to spawn a figure it's going to be
sitting right there
so we've normalized our scene now
and let's give it a render see what we
can see we can see
ooh johnny there's a plugin called drop
to floor that sends any object to the
floor in one click that sounds nice i'm
gonna write that down
sweet
all right what's going on here why is it
dark
um
oh
it's because we moved all this stuff
without moving the lights
so let's grab the lights
and
just bring them back
and you can see how you see
the flags in here
you can basically hide them all from
camera by selecting them
and adding a
to all of this stuff
right click c40 octane tags give it a
c40 tag give it an
octane tag
and set
visibility to
camera visible so you uncheck that
but that's like a nice um
now if i come in here and we go point
point five so it's a really large image
let's see if we can't find that
reflection also we need to change all
these shaders
because
they're giving you like a metallic look
and we just need to set it to the
correct
profile basically so
i'm going to select everything
[Music]
and with everything selected all those
materials selected
let's go up to
let's give it a second so the program
doesn't crash on me
fingers crossed
yeah we're gonna get imperfections on
the floor and everything we're making
this look really nice
oh
oh
saved
saved okay so save a new iteration
and let's change the material type
from universal to glossy
and from brdf to octane
and that'll kind of make things look a
bit more normal
so let's take a look at our assets
here um
let's get them
let's get this down to like 200
awesome
all right so we got this guy
we got a tiny little potato
i'm gonna render region
that way it goes a little bit faster
pumpkin
another pumpkin
and we can adjust it's a piece of garlic
we can adjust
a banana um
how glossy these guys are
that's actually pretty funny
like having this really ornate setup and
just having like one piece
of something
piece of bread
this all looks delicious
those are our grapes we'll have to want
to get those going
maybe we set up the grapes let's set up
the grapes because they're going to give
us some nice reflection
so the first thing to do is normalize
these guys
and we need the gizmo
going the right way
we'll bring this up we'll use the enable
axis or the axis center tool
with
include children use all objects that
way it's actually sitting on the ground
now
and
all right let's rotate this guy around
something like that um i'm gonna go with
a
a
darker background let's go like
point two on this
all right and then let's texture these
grapes up yeah
so subsurface scattering on the grapes
right
that's what we're going for
what i mean by that is the light will
pass through the grapes just like the
light passes through
your finger when you shine a flashlight
through it that's that's subsurface
scattering
it makes it look like it's glowing from
the inside
you kind of see it here
they look a little translucent
so
um i'm gonna make a
you have to make two materials to do
this unless you can use a
mixed material in octane
or it's more of a it's a universal
material so you have
specular
as well as transmission we need both
to get that um so instead of mixing two
together you just do it with a with a
universal i don't need metallic
don't need
an isotropy and an isotropic yeah
anisotropic you don't need that that's
where it's like the
the
the highlights are streaked out like you
would see on like a stainless steel
refrigerator or something we don't need
film layers or coating layers
um
this should be good
sheen layer we don't need that
hmm i'm trying to figure out how to get
this to uh octane universal
uh
all right so the color of this thing we
want it to be like uh
we can i think we can reference outside
of the program so we can do
a dark color like that
and we can mix it so we'll kind of mix
these different materials together
and it has
some roughness
but this to me is looking
really shiny
is it
the index of reflection
maybe this needs to be zero
i don't know why that's not working
maybe we do it this way maybe this is
the way we have to do it
at least the way i know to do it
uh what's the difference between
roughness and specular workflow well
roughness
tells you how
sharp a reflection will be so if i were
to put this material on the grapes
you can see how sharp the reflection is
here
you can really see that window that we
made
but if i take the roughness that that's
that's specular so specular is how
how shiny is it
right and then roughness is
how spread out is that reflection
so that looks like a balloon
you know
or something
at one and it's zero it's like a
glossy surface so i like to set that i
think this is like point two
or maybe point one
for a grape and it's
we can spend all day on a grape shader
but let's just try and keep it as simple
as we can for now
so you're getting that you're getting
the the specular
but you also want
the subsurface scattering which is going
to be transmission transmission you're
going to get through
a
a
brain fart
a diffuse material you're gonna get that
through a diffuse material okay so i'm
gonna put that on the grapes that's our
diffuse material let's reference
the color
out here
something like that maybe a little bit
more purpley
and we'll mix these colors
we'll get some mixture of color in here
and then you want the transmission
to be
cranked a bit so if we actually take
this
and we try and get a light
kind of color in through here
you're going to see they look like they
they're almost glowing from the inside
which is exactly what we want
like gummies you know little gummies
so then from here
what we can do is let's see
i wish we could like add
something to that we have to mix these
together
so i'll go to
my octane node view the node editor
and i'm going to grab a mix material
and we want to mix together
this diffuse material with this specular
material so i'll drag that up in here
pop that in
and you're getting a mixture of both of
these now
it's the transmission with
the specular
um and you can crank the transmission to
really
you know
get you something a bit brighter
but that looks that looks gross
you have to find the right
you really have to work with it and find
the right vibe you know
but i think it's going to be a mix so
the diffuse is going to be a mix between
like an rgb spectrum
so we'll let's see let's do a mix
material
or a mixed node
that's going to mix two colors together
and i can select
i'm just choosing colors off camera here
so i'm going between these two and i can
do that with like a noise or something
um
octane noise
and that
oh not noise i want specifically octane
noise
because that gives you
the uv options
give it a projection node
set it to
xyz to uvw and a transform node
and we'll pipe it into the diffuse
and we can transform it way down
and actually let's take the contrast to
100 so we can see what it's doing there
we go
0.05 and then let's give it uh
8 octaves and 0.8 on the omega and let's
take the gamma down so it's more
splitting between those two colors
yeah something like that and then we'll
take the the contrast down to like 20
or
even even five
is good
and we'll make sure that's piped into
the diffuse so it's going between those
two colors and those are red grapes
so i need to i need to adjust those
colors
and i'll go in here and also make sure
that this mixed
node setup
is copied
and pasted into the specular as well
so that's a start and we can do green
grapes too
but i feel like
we need more light pushed through those
grapes so now what we can also do
is start messing with uh
with our lighting so we can take this
light here
duplicate it ctrl drag
get rid of all this stuff
let's uh let's bring it
closer
and actually here's the trick you can go
to cameras use camera and set active
object as camera so now i am the light
and i'm coming in here
and i'm going to just get right in here
and shine it on these grapes
and
well
actually i did the wrong one
ctrl shift z will undo camera moves
so we need to select the right light and
then do that again cameras use camera
set
and then we can get in here
and then we'll go back into our normal
camera
and that light is way too intense
so we want to
bring it down
and then maybe take up the the intensity
just a little bit
whoa okay so that obviously looks like
that because the light needs to be
backed off
and for that i feel like we would need
a spotlight almost
or we could up the light bounces
you
all right so
let's start building out
this set up here we want to go for
something vertical
kind of in
this kind of feeling here
and
this is our reference currently as to
what we're looking at
lighting wise
so maybe we need to build out like a
series of like stacked
um
[Music]
like tiers or something
for stuff to stand on
and maybe we find a
background let's first look for a
surface that we like that way we can
get away from this white look
so those surfaces and we'll either do
concrete or marble
let's try marble
um
rough marble
and i like the idea of something like
neutral tone actually this marble floor
is not bad
let's try downloading that
and we can make it as shiny as we want
and we'll export it
and again we need to change it from
universal to glossy and then to octane
and we'll need to make a couple
adjustments
so i'll apply it and you can see
actually it looks really cool let me
undo for a second um
and we want to lay it over architecture
just everything as a whole
um
why it's reacting like this okay i need
to delete this stuff
there we go
so you can see the mapping is off here
try to hop out
you can see it's stretched in certain
places more so than others
and the best way to deal with that is to
go into the material
and we need to give it a projection
node
so let's see
let's open this up all right so
basically
you have a projection slot
and we have different options as to how
to project the textures that i'm
plugging this into
across
the geometry
so now that everything's plugged in
if we look at the render view
as we change this texture projection
i'll change it to box
and you can see how it now more
uniformly
spreads itself around this and xyz to
uvw also good does a good job sometimes
in this case it doesn't it usually works
with noise really well but i think box
is usually the one that works for us the
most
um
so let me go back into camera view
that looks really cool
um
let me
darken it a little bit so
as you can see here with bridge and
quixl
it transfers over really easily and
actually gives you full control over all
this stuff already so i'm going to take
the
gamma let's take the gamma up to like
or maybe 0.5 other way 2
um
and the saturation to 0.7
i don't like that though
maybe it's just brightness
will bring down the brightness
something like that
oh also another thing with the
architecture
i want to bevel these edges here
so
what we can do is put that boolean in a
null object and then hold shift and give
that a bevel
and hopefully i think
should be able
yep okay so that works but it needs to
be a single object
in order for it to truly work but then
we have really janky uh
stuff going on here
so
maybe that's just
maybe we have to just move the cylinder
around a little bit
oh that's horrible
okay uh maybe we take the segments down
to like 50 and then we move it around a
little bit again
this is just the
the issue
with the using a boolean because it
really messes up your
your geometry but i think that
mostly works um
if we come in just a little bit
like that that actually works as janky
as that is
it actually works
okay now the lighting is off again
so i want to again get this lighting to
match it's really dark on this side but
very light it looks like they're hitting
it with a spotlight like right here
that's what it looks like
well the round edges on the octane
shader could work as well
let me go in
and let's take the specular
let's mess with the roughness and
specular though real quick
because
we might be able to make this thing like
really shiny
and look really nice ooh
something like that
we're actually getting a bit of the
reflection from the light
if i plug the roughness back in
i can get just a little bit
from there from that
and i unplug the specular that way
you're getting a little something from
the stone so that feels kind of cool i
like that
um but let's wrap this light around a
little bit more this window light
what i'll do is make sure
check camera is unchecked that way
i can hop out on my camera
go into my light
my octane light and i can go to cameras
use camera set as active object
so i can kind of orbit the scene like
this
maybe turn down the light
that's pretty cool
and maybe the light needs to be a little
smaller
or is that bigger i can't tell when
we're literally the light
so maybe it's a little smaller but
set to like 60 or something
and then we definitely need some bounce
light down here
so
what i would do and also
we kind of need
a box as well we need a box down here
to be
the actual like
you know the base of this so i'll put
that architecture i'll put that in
architecture so it's textured too
and then i'll give it a bit of bounce
light by making a
a plane
rotating it around
angling it
bringing it down here
and scaling it down
so we're getting this bounce light
very subtle
and if we give it a diffuse
material
we'll be able to control how much bounce
there is so with uh
let's see if i set it to zero if i just
set it to black we're not going to get
any bounce light but if i set it to like
a light gray we'll get a little
something which is totally what you want
you want just a little
a little something down there
and
it'd be nice to see
this cube
oh so the bounce card we can see it we
don't want that um so let's select it
give it an octane tag visibility and
uncheck camera visible
so that way it's not in the way
and let's see at what point does this
cube make itself known
so you're really losing that down there
but we can make it a second bounce card
scale it way up
and try to
position it
back here
make a second material
and make it a little bit brighter
put it on that bounce card and maybe
we'll see a little bit of
the stone underneath here
all right
so that's just a little trick there
using the bounce cards to get that look
and it looks like i was in the camera so
i'm gonna undo this a bunch
until i'm back
i think that's it
yep
sweet
ooh it'll be interesting
this could be interesting um
we could
have all of these objects be floating
like a that's actually a different way
to do okay i like this
yeah you make them float that way it
gives it a
special
added kind of feeling this the updated
modern version of it they're floating in
the air versus sitting down on the
ground that's boring
um
art day what do you mean can i move my
window to the side
well i'm really bright
i'm really bright huh
let me turn this down
all right
so let's figure out like a fun
a fun like look that looks like a brick
i'm deleting
that this guy
maybe
maybe
but to me that r that reads loaf of
bread
that reads loaf of bread to me
so i'll keep this one
i like this idea i like the floating
idea i think it's gonna work
um
yeah let's keep that let's keep that
so that's i'll just put that up there
uh this guy is
kind of looks like bread
maybe i don't know i'll hide it for a
second
yes this this feels like bread to me
i like that a lot
as a little croissant
the ham i definitely feel like the ham
has to be in
you gotta find the right angle for it
but we'll adjust all the angling and
stuff in a second
um
let's keep going through the ones we
want to keep
that is a
a lemon
let's definitely keep the lemon
i like that
this is hard to tell it's hard to tell
what this is
i'm probably going to lose the i think
that's an apple that's an eaten apple
let's lose that one
i have a few of them
yeah let's lose that
oh wait
i don't know maybe i'll keep that i like
the shape of it i like the way the light
bounces off of it
this is just a straight up mango
that's kind of cool
a banana i gotta keep the banana
i love that
garlic clove i'm down
pumpkin
i like the pumpkin but i feel like we
should just use one pumpkin
and that's a pretty classic pumpkin
right there
doesn't that lighting look so nice i
love it
ah man it's like so soft
really dig that lighting style
this is a
potato but it's hard to tell
what it is so i might just delete the
potato we can always grab it back if we
need it
that's a gourd i'm cool with that right
now we have a lot of like yellow
green orange
um
color palettes so
i'm gonna keep moving through here
i'm gonna delete that bread i know i
don't want that
this bread i'm happy to delete that one
it's a straight up apple um
let's bring all these guys in
let's turn them all on
don't worry the pickle will happen the
pickle will happen
ronan what's up hey we decided to
actually have all of our
ingredients floating in the air i think
it's going to be way cooler
and it'll be a fun take on the still
life
photography and painting that you always
see
so
that's the direction right now that's a
red apple
that's a very red apple
fruit ninja
oh having some floating candles i think
will be super cool so maybe we keep the
the the candle there
just off to the side here
the bowl i could see the fruit like like
if everything just went
you know
so then the fruit would be coming out of
the bowl maybe so i i could see us
keeping this bowl off to the side
now this
to me
i don't know about that one i don't know
about that piece of bread
we'll keep that bowl as well
um
i don't know what that is oh that's a
a gourd or something
it's another potato we can delete that
i'm just going for stuff i can tell what
it actually is
like that ginger i can't tell what that
is
this piece of ginger
more so i can tell i can tell what that
is
what is this
oh that's the pickle
yeah maybe there's some picklage
going
this is the carrot
okay
it's another carrot
and a cucumber
okay
that's a lot of stuff
and another candle holder all right so
this is everything we need
for our still life
explosion
we'll adjust stuff
um
you know we'll make things look
correct in terms of composition and
whatnot but i think this is a fun
direction i really like this and i want
to
hmm i feel like
if we want to match this vibe it needs
to be a bit more contrasty
so i think what we can do is go to our
render here oh yeah
and turn up the
light
brightness
and change it to
yeah i think i think daylight 6500 is
good
4200
yeah let's try to turn this up
something like that
i'm feeling that i like that a lot
um and then we can adjust
the you know the actual color and
everything in photoshop later if we get
that far if we have enough time already
two hours in
jay what's up dude
i shaved the beard i did it
yeah man next is a haircut i desperately
need one of those
um but yeah um
basila basila i do the whole thing in
stream that is the point that's the
whole point of this so i'm very excited
we're very close we have everything that
we need to do our still life
but jay what i decided to do actually is
have it be floating in the air like this
i think if we can get a really nice
composition in the air it could look
really cool
so maybe we try and do some sort of like
explosion of fruit
and vegetables
and i'll probably throw some nuts in
there too as like different particles
i think that could be a really really
cool look i don't know what would be on
the ground maybe candles would be
underneath or something i don't know yet
but
yeah let's start placing this stuff
um
maybe the heavy objects are down on the
ground
and we have like a bowl or something in
the back
that's like tilted up like this
that's kind of blowing out all the
different fruit
so we could have an apple
boom with like a
i don't know too many pumpkins
you don't want too many pumpkins
now the bowl of grapes
that could be cool to have like some
grapes popping out like this
some other grapes popping out like this
so they're just out there
so get our fruit bowl going
launching stuff out
the banana
up and out here like this maybe the
bread
so this is going to be probably the next
30 minutes is like
placing all of
these pieces of fruit here
in an interesting way that feels right
because you want to be able to tell
like what is what
when you're working with all this stuff
and you want to be able to show each one
of these pieces in their best light
so maybe it starts from like a central
point
and blows out
outwards
let me just google real quick
i think this is going to help us
if we google fruit
explosion
and we see what there is
on youtube
we can or sorry i'm not on youtube on
google
we can get an idea of how to position
this stuff
exploding food
that's pretty cool that's a pizza going
off
that's fun
um
floating food maybe
see this works like with like a burger
you know
um oh this is cool
yeah that's well done i like that
here's kind of an example
the bowl with the stuff coming out of it
you can see that everything is like
very precisely placed
which is definitely what we want we
don't want to go too crazy with it i
think we might have to
we won't be able to keep all of our
objects
here's one
very clearly shows
three things of ice cream the oreos and
yeah it's like it's kind of symmetrical
this is right now it's just a lot
so
i think people know
what a still life is i think they get
the idea
um
so we definitely want we want to allude
to that as much as we can
i think the grapes are classic for a
still life it totally like
alludes to that
um
[Music]
same for
let's see let's check our references
i mean the pumpkins definitely
i feel like we need a bottle of wine or
something too
that actually
might help this process
and some nuts you want some smaller
things flying around as well
maybe some leaves
in the background
i think the ham is killing us
so i'm going to hide the ham for a
second
but i don't know you got ham in this one
you know
at least that looks like hammer dead
leather
looks kind of gross
apples and grapes
definitely and i like the pumpkin
and maybe a platter
and like a vase or something so let me
check
what's up casey
yeah the the um a bottle with fluid
coming out would definitely be cool but
i do not have time to do a fluid sim
right now
he removed the ham
dude how could you
yeah the cucumber's killing it
not a fan let's hide that maybe we'll
bring the ham back
maybe
maybe
okay i want to find a vase
or something so
3d assets
interior
decoration
kitchenware
something i can put glass around
that would actually look like it would
be made of glass most of this stuff is
like stone
pitchers
tableware
hmm
yeah these these vases could work um
maybe i'll grab this guy
and i know polygon has wine bottles i
would love to do a wine glass i think
that's gonna
that reads very um
still life drawing
and i might already have it downloaded
let's check
books microwaves plate and bowl set oven
stove pots and pans teapot
silver teapot maybe
let's
try um
i have to reload these textures all
right all right
polygon
teapot silver textures 4k
specular
load
ah
hmm
reflection
the reflection specular
gloss specular
and the normal specular
and yeah that gets you a teapot
but i don't know about that i think you
need the wine bottle
i think you really need that wine bottle
there it is wine bottles sweet alright
boom
comes with
two three of them
so let's re-link these textures real
quick
polygon
wine bottles textures
dang it why are these these are all off
color
reflection
gloss
re-linking textures is probably like the
most exciting thing you could be doing
right now
reflection
all right
normals
and the color why okay colors and
transmission
hmm it doesn't look right it certainly
doesn't look right
let me double check this we need the
wine bottle we definitely need the wine
bottle
let me head over to polygon real quick
all right c4d octane
4k is fine
okay let's give this one more shot shall
we
it's downloading
let's get rid of these guys
i don't know about that teapot i'll
leave it in that way we don't have to
undo work
all right
extracting the wine bottles
hmm
let's delete these
sorry all
let's see if opening it up on its own
we'll do the trick
there we go okay that looks way better
let's copy these guys we'll bring them
in
yeah a bottle of wine with the wine
spewing out i think would definitely
help
but
again i don't think i have time to do a
a fluid sim
right now that'd be a lot
all right
basia bacilla i like that the pumpkin
falls and hits the plate and everything
flies off just to add some story cool
i like that
so we got white wine and the dark wine i
like the dark wine
that red one back here i think is the
one
uh-oh
don't crash on me
how are you all guy how are y'all guys
doing hi how's everybody doing thumbs up
everybody you guys doing okay still
hanging on hanging in there
still learning stuff um
this is a process it just it goes slow
um
[Music]
it really starts coming together once
you know once we get all the pieces in
place and then it's like oh this is
looking good i really am very happy with
the lighting we have set up it's just
getting this stuff placed
is basically the last thing we have to
do and then we'll announce the winners
of last week's weekly challenge which
was to animate a walk cycle so we'll get
into that and we'll issue the new
challenge
um it might be to make your own still
life
it might be i think there's a high
chance that that will be
the challenge but
you know we'll see when we get there
let's see if we can salvage c4d
it's auto saving the wine
uh
project file that's in the background
right now
all right let's go ahead and force quit
and we'll do it we'll do this thing
right
we'll get some surface imperfections
there on the uh
on the wine bottle too we'll get we'll
get surface imperfections all up in this
don't worry just need to get the
composition right
and then we'll go into the details
you
all right we'll render our scene and
we'll place our objects
justin
oh
i don't even say anything i'll just
shake my head
and yeah sodamonte actually i think you
were here before you left for dinner but
uh we're gonna do them all in the air
exploding in the air which i think is
super cool
and kippah i'm glad you're enjoying the
stream thanks guys
okay let's get our wine bottle going
and we
want not the clear one
but it's one of these guys
i think it's this one it's the purple
one
where's that one green i think that
one's green yeah that's the one we want
them or low
so let's try this let's try
we had this
platter on the ground
and
it blasted the pumpkin fell
on this thing right here
and it'd be cool to actually give all
this some motion blur too maybe i'm not
sure some slight motion blur
and it blasted everything
around here
and out
so maybe what i'll do
is
i mean that's that's kind of taking
shape a little bit
the banana goes flying the merlot
goes flying this way
the bread is going up in the air
and i think you have like smaller things
like pickles
like you you lay out the large things
and you fill in the gaps with the small
stuff
you want to try not to have
stuff in the way
shadow wise
other stuff now the roll can go up here
that's very bright that roll is very
very bright
so you got to be careful with that
the apples
are going up
and the grapes
maybe the grapes are up here
with the wine i like that
i don't know who
recommended this
but i really like the idea i appreciate
you
i appreciate the idea i think it's a
really good one
this is cool i'm liking how this is
turning out
john malcolm yeah having some objects
cast shadows on others might be nice too
um as i'm having the clearest glass
bottle near the front and seeing
um
seeing stuff through it agreed
yeah i think that could be pretty sweet
um
so we're gonna keep messing with it like
definitely this is like stage one
is getting all this stuff
lined up like this
and then we'll have other stuff we'll
give it some depth in terms of like z
space
and i'll probably duplicate some of
these things like the
the smaller stuff we can duplicate
and the lemon i think we can duplicate
the lemon
i feel like we can put the ham
this pumpkin could be maybe a little
bigger
the ham could
get right in here
the bread can go up in here because it's
a little lighter this piece can maybe
come forwards
and it will need some bounce light on
this other side
definitely need some bounce light on
this dark side
i don't know what's casting shadow on
the pumpkin
okay it's the other pumpkin
the ginger root
i think that's the ginger yep that's a
ginger root for sure
get that thing flying
don't know what that is back here okay
that's a carrot
oh no
ah it's frozen again
oh my goodness so scary
f
g
yeah i think i think detaching some of
the grapes definitely is a good move
to have them fly like particles in the
air
but i like our shader from this tiny
little view we have right here i think
our shader looks really good
i'm going to do a green version too for
these grapes down here
so you want everything to have a pretty
clear silhouette
when doing this
so you can actually tell what stuff is
it's all a matter of finding the right
angle
the right way to light all this stuff
that's the whole point of still life is
like finding the best angle for these
things
and it's really a great
exercise in lighting
let's take these grapes let's get them
up here
rotate them
and let's make a green shader for the
grapes
so i'm going to duplicate all three of
these guys
and
let's
give it a shot here so this one's gonna
be green
um
or i'm sorry the the transmission we
want to be green
on the inside glowing green
and the diffusion is made up from this
mix texture
and i'm just going to shift all these to
the green
hue
there we go green hue on this
and it's going to mix between
let's see this universal and the diffuse
so that looks like our green shader and
we'll apply that to
these grapes here
but i think they need to be brighter
so i'm going to come into
this guy and let's go like a brighter
lime
green
like that there we go that's already
looking better
and it's mixing with maybe
an even brighter
like white green yeah that feels nice
and the transmission
i think can really go
to town here
and we can actually take out the
lighting in our viewport
to see things a little bit better we can
also
let's see hit n q
to get rid of textures
so we can really
see what's going on here
but i'm i'm really digging this
a whole lot
i think this is fun
all right we got we got grape color
opinions let's see
all right maybe desaturate the green so
it fits the color palette
okay i feel like i need to brighten it
up a little bit too i think it should be
less saturated and a bit more yellow
all right
ah the fuse
we still need this stuff to be greenish
yellow
those purple ones look really nice
that's because we probably used a
reference so
something like this i think they need to
be a bit more white
so maybe that's the fusion or the
transmission
something like that
it's not bad
it's not bad you know what we can also
do
we can cheat and give it a fake light
and we'll set that to our
active object so we can like literally
get in here
and just give this its own like special
light and then we can duplicate that
let's see let's duplicate that
i think are we still a light
and then we'll hop out we'll go back to
the normal camera
and
lock our spot
i'm doing ctrl shift z to undo camera
moves and i'll take both of those grape
lights and i'll select the octane tag go
to visibility uncheck camera visible
and that way they're both getting
these like
technically it's cheating right they're
these like hidden lights
but
they're boosting actually here i don't
like that actually because it's boosting
the
the intensity of the background back up
and i like the fact that that's hidden
so
maybe we just leave it i think it looks
really nice
yeah that doesn't work
or maybe it's just a matter of like
adjusting the light a little bit
to get the right look
make it smaller maybe
rotate it around
yeah i don't think we need it i don't i
really don't think we need it i think
any of that stuff we can actually mess
with in photoshop too
um let's try and get a bounce card
though
to get the dark side of these fruits
so
let me
actually just use the one that we made
and try and bounce some light
back
onto the shadow side of these guys
and we can adjust the
material that's on that to bounce more
light so right now if we take it all the
way up to
white
you're going to get that bounce light
really intensely
but
setting it to 0.5 to get half of that
see that's too much we just need a
little bit
that's even too much
um
0.03
maybe something like that
and i still
i still want to feel out the
positioning of all this stuff
yeah getting some
some shadow on the background perhaps
could be cool
and then duplicating stuff
and you want to orient things in order
to
tell what they are
now where's that garlic
there it is
i like this garlic
but it's really bright right here so
maybe i just
i hide it
and then maybe this bowl could be like
launching maybe it's launching the
garlic
or something like this
use the transfer tool
to get the garlic in there
duplicate it
and the grapes we can actually we can
start detaching
some of these grapes and we can make
these apples even shinier too
so maybe
go into like say this apple texture
this green apple
and
let's do
[Music]
let's go into its actual material
and if we detach the specular
it might shine so here let me do uh
store the render buffer here let's take
off the specular
and see how it changed
there you go
you can see in this apple there's a
highlight
and it was gone before but now there's a
highlight and i want that highlight
and let's see if we can do the same
with the there you go you see you get
that nice highlight
in the apple i love that so i'm going to
adjust it
just enough i'm adjusting the roughness
so you can see it
and the pumpkin i feel like could use a
little bit too
so let me try it with the pumpkin
just a little bit it always feels like
it feels nicer
we have a little bit
of
that
reflection you can see it here in this
pumpkin
it's a little bit in there it's a lot on
that one
a little bit on these guys some on these
guys so there's always a little bit of
reflection that you want to keep
so
detach
there it is
detach the specular
and if i take the brightness of the
roughness all the way down you'll get
like a plastic pumpkin you definitely
don't want that
i think setting it to one is fantastic
that looks really good
it might be able to come down just a
little bit so i plug in the specular
and then maybe i just bring the specular
the power down
no that's not doing it
the specular let's see if i go to the
index is 1.3 if i go 1.1
it's going to come down a little bit
so maybe we just go to the specular
little tab here and we go 0.5 so it's
just half the amount
and we do like 0.8 on the brightness for
that that feels good to me
and let's do this other pumpkin here
same deal there but that's too much so
let's go to the specular tab let's go
like point
point three
that feels good
so i'm going to top view for this candle
piece so i can rotate it perfectly
on its edge
let's see
yep that feels right
and then let's adjust the axis
there we go
so we can tilt it
off axis like that
i think it's pretty nice
and this little guy can go
the wine bottle
i feel like the wine in the grapes can
go on the right here
so i like the positioning of all this so
i'm going to keep it
and just move it over
but the grapes actually did a little bit
better towards the light
so when we take the red ones and we
bring them towards the light because
they're darker and they need more light
and then we'll take the green ones down
here
this thing's throwing me
kent yeah dust in some atmosphere will
help soften and make it more painterly i
agree
um
so yeah how could we do that how could
we do that what are some ways we can do
that i think i'm still messing with the
placement of all this
but i agree with you i'm still i'm still
doing the touches here on the
i'm just trying to figure out the best
angle for all this stuff
and some motion blur could be really
cool too so
some things i want to do i want to take
the grapes and
um blast them across
the
the scene and i think that'll do it like
maybe i'll grab some nuts
and do that with that but let me
actually let me go into the
green grapes index and let's just set
that to two
so they're a bit more reflective i'll
take them away from the wall just a bit
i think it's the wine bottle
getting me the shadow here on the right
which i'm not the biggest fan of
hmm the candelabra i'm not feeling too
much
either
right maybe i take everything
and i want to get these grapes and wine
properly placed
i'm gonna move this over just a little
bit
and the one actually before i do this
i'm gonna save an iteration
move it over
grab the wine
try the wine on this side
don't think it works as well actually
because it's dark and the scene
on that side is dark dark on dark does
not work so we actually need lighter on
the left side and darker on the right
side
but i want to get rid of that
shadow here on the wall which is being
caused by the wine bottle so
maybe if i
pull it forward like that just a little
bit
and this apple i feel i can go
the carrot not the biggest fan of
unless we can get a better like angle on
it
and maybe the banana
let's see
so with the pointy objects it'd be cool
to get like a little
spiky array
going
so they're they're kind of like the
explosion lines
they're the anime lines you know but
you're doing it with the
with the veggies
so now everything feels up feels pretty
uniform
and i think
it's time to
get these grapes split up and
i'm actually going to try that same
trick on these guys to make them a bit
more
that's a bit intense um
1.5 maybe
all right so i'm going to check here to
see what's in the way of the light
between the light and the wine
bottle because i want to make sure there
are no shadows
on the wine bottle itself
and actually it looks like the red
grapes are casting
a pretty intense shadow on the wine
bottle so i'll bring them
here instead
that way we get more of that wine bottle
going
there's an apple back there that we
don't need
and that's not bad um
i think we can get rid of this guy
and maybe add some cheese
but let's do
let's do some grapes flying
around the scene
so the best way to do that i believe
is to
come in here let's grab one of these
grapes let's hop in
go to
polygon mode
and let's just go ahead and select one
of those polygons and hit u y a whole
bunch until
we get everything hit up it's going to
break it up
move it outside
and let's do it to one more
so we have
some variation
and then let's do it to the green ones
as well
and one more
so we have these all of these guys i'm
going to
center their axis
and i'm going to reset their position
scale rotation
um let's
try and get this right um
point center
reset psr
huh this should work
all for reset psr
and we got
some grapes right here cool
so what i'll do with that is basically
put these in a cloner so i'm gonna hold
ctrl alt
pop it in a cloner
and the cloner can be a grid array
that's fine three by three
uh maybe it's
six by six by six
and then we do a grid array yeah rent
multi instance is fine
and i think the distance is too much
right now so we'll do 10 by 10 by 10.
so we just got grapes everywhere
now we need to
let's try let's try five by five by five
actually
and it's way too uniform so we need to
randomize it
so what we'll do with the cloner
selected
let's go and grab a
random modifier and that's going to
randomize the position of everything
so
we're randomizing everything by 20
inches
and let's do the scale or the rotation
too so we can do 360 down the board
and you just want to make sure that
nothing is clipping through anything
like this grape on the left
and we're clipping through the ground
there so
you can take this back you can say like
three by three
because that's a lot of grapes um you
could do
maybe five by five
and we make it more of like a cluster of
grapes so we can take that size down to
two inches by two inches
and the random effector that we have
we can take that
to five inches in every direction
so it's more of a cluster of grapes that
we have here
um
and they'd be coming like from this way
something like this and i think we can
go a little bit larger on the spread so
we can go like
eight by eight
that's not bad actually i think that's
pretty cool
um
again you just want to make sure that
you're not clipping through any objects
with the grapes
and it doesn't look like we are right
now so that's good
matt i got you man thanks for joining
right
so
some dust what do you mean by dust do
you mean like a dust wave
um because that's going to be easiest in
like after effects with some actual vfx
elements or do you mean surface
imperfections on the marble because i'm
still not happy with the marble and the
way it looks so i think it's time that
we put a little bit of focus
into that i also think the left side of
the image is
lacking just a little bit so
maybe we could find something to put in
there
but um
let me see here let me see if like
the first thing i need to bevel this
edge on the architecture the floor
i think it comes with
the ability to do that
[Music]
let's see bevel
where would you be both bevels are
around okay size one inch
there we go
so like point two
point one
see how beveling the edge gets you a
little bit of highlight
without it
you have no highlight
and your renders look very fake but when
you do even the tiniest bevel point one
you get that nice little edge there
and it looks really nice
this looks real like this
it looks really good i'm very happy with
how this is looking
oh man it looks super cool
okay so for the background i'm wondering
if we can actually cool off
the background um
[Music]
by changing the intensity or the color
temperature of that marble
so i'm just trying to find it in here
there we go
even if i gray it out
let's just say i take the saturation to
zero
it's gonna look cooler
because of the contrasting um
you know colors in the foreground but i
don't think i want to quite do that um
[Music]
let's take the saturation back to one
but let's take the hue
around and see
what we can get all right so that's
very that feels very blue so the
saturation maybe needs to come down to
like
i don't know 0.5 but that feels gray
i don't like that
negative point five whoa
negative point one
that's a red
that's so crazy looking
wow that looks really fun
man this is a tough decision
i think the more classic we can go with
the background the better
and maybe
[Music]
let's see
maybe it's this light bounce
i'm kinda
i'm bouncing all over the place here
okay
so now i'm going to mess with some
octane camera options and try and give
it some bloom
hmm
i don't know why it's not
doing anything
i wonder if depth of field would be cool
too
maybe just a little bit 5.6
just a hair i don't want it to feel too
cg
hmm okay let's see
what could this use it's close it's very
close this is when i just sit here and
figure this out
um a spotlight could be interesting
let's try and
get that in there see what this looks
like
yikes
that's intense okay i definitely don't
want the volumetric
look
but maybe that could help
let's see let's see what we can do here
so the light medium
is i think the medium is what's doing
this
the density if we set the density to
zero
all right that's what we get if the
density is at zero
definitely a fan of the
the soft light
but i think some atmosphere could help
i think some atmosphere could could
certainly help
um
so let's try fog volume let's go for it
i'm thinking i'm just trying to think
about this here
boom there's a fog volume
medium
density let's go one
and
the
voxel size we can set to 100
push this back
so it's very subtle
and if we set it to like
wait where'd it go
that's weird
okay i think i just
hit the wrong button
oh yes a little bit of a little bit of
atmosphere i think could do a whole lot
that feels very nice and we can
take the scattering and give it a little
bit of blue
and i think that'll give us the blue
we're looking for
and it's very similar to this
coloring here
and maybe we take our
our volume and
we take the scattering phase up
or is it down
it's neither
absolutely neither okay
that is looking really cool
i'll get the light
pushed a little
more
that's not feeling half bad i think
maybe a little bit of motion blur a
little bit could help
could i explain the soft lighting um
yes
so
basically the idea is that you have a
lot one large light source
and that
really spreads out
the the shadow so
to give you an example here let me do
something really quick
so basically i hop out of camera and we
have this light here and i have these
bars going across the light to give it a
window look in the reflection also these
our cards blocking the light from
hitting you know say like this side of
the image it's more central
um but because the light is large
it is
giving you that soft look if i make the
light tiny
and i turn up the power
whoa
you're going to get those hard shadows
so the light is tiny
and the brightness level is about the
same
but you're getting those really gross
hard shadows
but when we take the light
back up to the proper size
you're getting really soft shadows which
is exactly what you want
awesome awesome okay so
let's go ahead and hop back in
and i think i figured out the
issue with the post-processing because
i'd love a little bit of diffusion
as well i think the fog might be a
little heavy
so 0.075
and then let's do
let's go back to the camera imager and
let's try and get that glow to happen i
think it's the light you need to uncheck
surface brightness
come down to maybe
75
and it's still not
getting us what we need that's weird
yeah i don't know why my post process
isn't working
let's check the vlog the fog edge
oh yep yep
certainly
there we go
thank you for that
yeah i don't know why the post process
isn't working it should work
with the check camera option checked it
should be working maybe i just restart
uh
octane nope that's not doing it
oh the gsg 3d dust
could be interesting i feel like i want
to do all that in in after effects
though
this looks pretty good to me
i think the last thing i want to get in
here is some cheese
so
i'm going gonna go ahead and open up
some polygon cheese
and let's uh let's see here
ah do i not have any two seconds here
let me get some polygon cheese going
absolutely love this website it's the
best
um let's do
models
and food
and we don't search for wine but we want
to find here's a cheese plate
right up in here that's some good stuff
oh a split
lemon would be nice too
let's go for the brie i'm a fan
all right cheese is going
and let's check the marble texture and
let's move around the
the transform here
just want to find the right angle on it
maybe we take the scale up
not bad not bad
let's get our cheese going
[Music]
bam beautiful
the polygon models are so well done they
look so good
boom we got our
cheese and let's i'm gonna
close this down close project
all right
so we need to find the premium angle
for our premium cheese
as soon as the program is not frozen
we will do that
i'm very excited about this i think it
turned out really nice
whoa it's so bright
sorry guys
you ain't gonna tell me
no it's on auto settings
it's just because it keeps getting
brighter out here i should just set it
to auto to be honest
all right
thank you thank you
tom moore yeah i'm getting r23 man for
sure i'll stay up to date with c4d all
right we got our cheese in
let's scale it up
we don't need the whole piece we
definitely want the pacman
and underneath is the wedge
you
maybe it's like rolling off the edge or
something
there we go
that's what we needed
all right i'm really feeling it i think
the last thing we need is just some nuts
coming off the front
right in the foreground right here
we need it
uh what the heck come on get out here
just not the coconut the coconuts too
much
oh snap we got 21 points left
four
i think we only need two of those and
one of those
bam
all my quicksill points
it was worth it though
ah
and wait what is it wait what
oh all right let's export those
y'all about this pickle
i don't know about the pickle man i
don't know
get reservations with the pickle
but let's see if we can't
get some nuts coming off of this thing
see what this looks like
and you want to rotate this stuff so you
can tell what the heck it is
it's hard to like randomly
do this though
all right that's cool i feel like i
could i could spend a while doing this
um
i think the the man i keep saying i
think the last thing
um how do i get this painterly feel to
my 3d scenes well
one is the reference definitely going
for the reference so i'm referencing
that old style
lighting or not old style lighting it's
it's the
still life effect it's a very soft
light
i'm just using one large light source
and a little bit of uh fog
and i'm just placing these objects
around to make it feel
you know
like there's some cohesion to what's
going on
so i think the the
couple things couple last things here
it could use some motion blur
and maybe
some surface imperfections
on the marble perhaps
um
we're kind of losing the bottom of this
thing
a little bit i'm trying to think of like
the best way
to make this look really nice
i mean we could straight up just get a
light down here
something very subtle
like i could grab the same light
and
pilot the light
just right in here
but here's the thing that i want to get
i don't want to get
the veggies and everything i don't want
to get the scene
so
let's hop back into the camera
that looks like an american apparel ad
it looks horrible
let's uncheck check camera
let's take this light
and see if we can't
flag the light so
none of it hits our scene and it just
hits the bottom
so i'm gonna set this to like
five
and let's bring it up
you can see how we are seeing the bottom
a little bit down there
that's what i'm going for
just a little bit down there
and i'm going to
flag this off
because it's lighting up
our actual scene which we don't want
so let's grab this guy
reset psr
and see if we can't
block this light
from hitting the rest of our scene
and maybe we have to move it closer
so we'll do a
compare here we'll store the render
buffer
that's with the light let's turn the
light off
and see the difference
and you can see how it's not really
affecting
our scene except for the bottom
where we're seeing a bit more shadow
which is
or we're seeing a bit more into the
shadow which is what i want i don't want
to be black i want it to be lifted just
a bit
so
i want to render a
z depth pass maybe for a bit of dust or
something as well so we can we can
actually
mess with that in after effects i know
there's probably a way to do it in
in photoshop but i've not had good luck
with
z depth passes in photoshop
so
let's go ahead and set that up in my
render settings
why can't i do that wow i can't go that
far okay in my render settings i go to
the octane renderer
and
under
render passes we can go to info passes
and check the z depth pass and you
should get
oh is it because of the lock
oh you have to enable
um
you have to go to main yeah render
passes you have to enable it
and then you'll get the z depth
option down here and you can actually
slide this up and down
and get a proper z depth pass
so that'll be it we just want one frame
so let's set this up i want to save this
to
let's see episode still life and we have
render output
and i'll call this z
oh maybe that's why i can't use it in
photoshop is because
it's set to linear
maybe that's why
i don't know we'll give it a shot
and then let's go to the output
and let me double check my aspect ratio
one last time
one last time here
um okay
all right forty four ninety two
sixty seven seventy four
forty
44.92
67.74
all right
so that's two by three right yeah
two by three
or um two hundred by three hundred
great all right so that changes our
aspect ratio just a little bit
that shouldn't be a big deal
makes it a bit taller okay
but we can just kind of move this in a
little bit let me hide this stuff
all right awesome
maybe we just pull some of these guys up
a little bit
you
awesome i can mess with this all day
as you can get as you guys can see
oh the pickle
the pickle it was revealed
my god
i don't know i don't think the pickle
does it for me man
i think the pickle's got to go you know
we tried
you know or unless
for anyone who knows
there's a pickle down here
it's way down there but there's a pickle
hiding
just waiting
all right
is it time we hit the render button
all right i think it's time
we could add you know
nut dust and
all this and that but
i think it's time i'm gonna take down
the grape spillage i'm gonna i'm gonna
adjust the grape spillage
one last time
one last time here we go
the randomness of the grapes
let's just get those up to like
five by five
so they're all over the place
and we'll get them up there a little bit
and that feels good
and the banana
all right i think that's it
i think that's it
all right i think i'm done
i have to be done at some point
i'm very happy with how this turned out
though i think this looks really
good ah
this guy that's a content aware phil
issue
that i will deal with
later
i'll fix it in post
okay
i think it's time
and i think that works a lot better
okay
okay
it's time to render i have to i have to
render
all right
i'm doing i gotta hit render now
um okay save let's do
an exr
16 bit is fine
and we'll do this uh v1
samples what do we want 2500
yeah 2500 samples and then let's do
diffuse 32 scatter depth 32
scattered f16
so we're really upping the samples here
getting those light bounces looking
really good and i'm going to hit
render on this guy and actually last
thing before i do that let me just
double check that the post process thing
is
confirmed and not working i don't know
why that's not working
that's driving me crazy
well we can do it later too so here let
me just uh
hit render on this bad boy
all right so while that goes
that's a large image
that is one large image
crazy
i'm very excited for this
okay so while that's going i think it's
finally time to
oh the motion blur it's too late it's
too late maybe i'll do it later but
basically the way i do that is
literally just take everything animate
it a little further out into space and
then find the in between frame add the
motion blur and choose how much motion
blur i want
that might be the way to go that might
be the way to do this but
for the sake of you know getting through
to the end of this stream i got a truck
on forward here let me turn up actually
i really need to just get this on on
auto
but man i'm super happy with that and
how that looks i think it looks so nice
ah that's awesome and i'll have to do a
thumbnail version for youtube
oh my goodness
so
without further ado it's time
to announce the winners of the weekly
challenge that i host every single week
hence a weekly challenge
and
this last week was the challenge was to
render out um
a a walk cycle
so i'm going to go through all the
submissions here on the stream
and we're going to judge them we're
going to pick five winners
for this thing
um
and uh it's gonna be a good time then
i'm gonna announce the new challenge for
this week
which might be to create your own still
life
render
but uh
more on that in two seconds here let me
just save my
my reference
all right
so
here we go
bam
so let's take a look at these uh walk
cycles and see which ones are gonna win
top five we've got five winners on this
one so let's go through them all
oh wow
tinum
going above and beyond here
what's going on
it's so dark i don't know what's
happening
okay here we go here we go
bam bam
it's like so mechanical
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's great
wow that's really good
that's a lot of work
oh my goodness
so the walk cycle itself oh man that's
that's amazing
that's so funny yeah um let's talk about
it let's talk about this walk cycle so
the walk cycle itself all the work that
you did for the dancing incredible like
hats off to you
uh you went above and beyond
fantastic but let's talk about the walk
cycle
the walk cycle felt a little robotic a
little stiff to me
a little staccato-y like
you know of course there's going to the
music and everything but it's like the
arms feel locked
like this
versus you know like just like a
more of a natural walk but you you get
points you certainly get points ten them
so let me let me write this down from
last time
last time we got six winners
so i'm gonna make sure we do five this
week so ten of them are you're on the
list i think that's fun
all right cool showing your renders and
everything good stuff good stuff
uh sharp aluminum flavor you're always
putting out good work the moonwalk
that's fun
look at that
that's really cool
that's really cool now here's the trick
do you have
the correct foot locked
it's hard to tell
oh the moonwalk
the foot that's actually sliding is the
foot that looks flat
so
the tippy toe foot
should be locked to the ground but i
don't think it is
it's hard to tell
no i think it is
it is yeah the tippy toe foot is locked
to the ground this is fun sharp aluminum
flavor i like it technically not a walk
cycle
but
we'll get back to it you know we'll see
we'll see let's take a look at this one
abilash
all right now a little little difficult
to tell what the character is very
abstract
but it is indeed a walk cycle that was
the whole point of this thing
not bad little robotic
um you know if you if you walk like this
little robotic it's really hard doing
this stuff is very difficult but
the character is walking and it cycles
so that's good
so good work to you good i hope you
learned a lot during that
um guillermo
it says please be gentle
okay let's take a look at caramels
it looks like the t-1000
all right so this one hard to tell the
characters walking i think it's lit well
it's rendered well i like it you got
some fog and some steam going
but
because it's front on it's difficult to
tell if i was walking towards you with a
long lens it'd be hard to tell versus a
walk cycle from this way be a little bit
easier to tell
um
stiff and robe it's a bit stiff and
robotic i mean the character is a robot
so actually hats off to you points to
you on that i think that's nice
but i'm still missing the walk cycle i'm
missing i'm missing like some character
so far tenem is the only one to add and
have some character to his walk cycle um
render warrior let's take a look i know
this was based off of a uh
based off of a cg what's his name
cg geek video
it's not bad it's kind of funny
it's pretty funny
very out there very goofy
very janky but i think it's funny so
um
points to you for that so render warrior
i think you're on the list here
tinum you said you you
you
sent the video as a different one
oh this one here
thank you
so with this one it feels like they're
slipping it feels like he's slipping and
sliding his foot isn't actually making
contact with the ground and like pushing
him forward
looks like a little slippy little slidey
action going on and it looks like
slow-mo
but it's not bad
it's certainly not bad like you're
leading with the hips
um and you're reaching with the feet so
you're like leaning with the hips and
reaching with the feet and
you kind of got that going so that's
actually not not a bad job you are still
in the running so no worries
brenda warrior
all right
let's keep it up
klepsie
oh here we go
love me some spirited away
that's not a bad walk cycle actually
i feel like her arms are a little long
though they go down to her knees
it's intense
um
but i mean
the character's great uh what's her name
chihiro
i love the way you rendered it
i think it's very fun and your walk
cycle is very natural it feels very
natural minus the long
like ape arms
that's the only thing that gets me
but this one is good i'm gonna write
this one down okay
so i'll keep you keep you in the running
collapsy
all right tristan what you got for me
all right sweet so this one guys like i
said doing this kind of stuff is
hard
is
very very difficult
um
so
fantastic work to everyone who even like
tried this thing because
it's really difficult stuff animation is
my weak point um so
because everyone knows what someone
walking looks like it's second nature to
everybody and when they see something
that's off they're like yep that's off
so with this it's definitely a cycle so
good job um
in this case you always want to animate
to reference always always always
animate to reference that's like the
biggest thing when you're animating
gotta do it to reference so this
character spider-man is running very
upright i feel like he'd be his chest
would be forward and he'd be his
shoulders he'd see it in his shoulders
and his head would be hunched down
you know he's very upright in this case
um running like like this
you know kind of like a
little bit more robotic-y but the render
is nice i love the helicopter coming in
the background
and you have
some
distortion and stretching with the
costume which is great
i think that's a really good job
but i'm missing the
oh here's what it is it's the hips
there's no bob up and down with the run
the hips are staying on the same line so
you need that boom boom you'd be
shifting your weight from one side to
another again easier said than done
really hard work um
but good job tristan really good job
all right this one's not bad
that's a walk cycle for sure absolutely
good job with the character good job
with the render
i feel like the character's sliding a
little bit on the ground but it's hard
to tell because
there's no texture on the ground
so
the ground could be whipping by at a
million miles an hour and we wouldn't
know
but based on i guess this light source i
don't know
this one yeah no this one's not bad it's
definitely a walk cycle um
i think it feels it still feels a little
stiff you know these are all feeling a
bit stiff
that's my biggest thing
try and use reference and
and really work on the stiffness i think
it's in the arms that i'm seeing here
it's
it's very it's very like this
versus
letting it swing and letting your arm
swing and catch up
unless this guy's so jacked like that's
like a 90 degree
you know angle right there and he's
basically keeping that the whole time
so you're getting this look
you know like that it's very difficult i
can't say it enough this is very very
difficult
all right mr ant
it looks looks like he's swimming almost
very interesting it's difficult to tell
difficult to see here um
yeah it looks more like a like he's
swimming than
um he's walking and it's difficult
because you need to have the feet
make
contact with the ground he's floating
above the street
and
the foot that's planted isn't planted
and this gets into
uh inverse
and forward kinematics i believe it's
inverse kinematics that allow you to
grab a hold of something like a like a a
wall here and be able to move around
like this
same for the foot when it's on the
ground it's moving and the knee and the
hip are moving but the foot is staying
planted and that's really what you need
when you're doing walk cycles like this
so mr ant good work um thank you for
participating and i hope you learned a
lot as i am
learning a lot watching you guys do this
and seeing how difficult this really is
so i really appreciate everyone doing
this this is a early submission by
render warrior
this guy here
okay some
weird animation based on some weird
references
but at least
this actually isn't bad because the
character in the background actually has
some rhythm to him and he's moving that
neck in a nice way and he's getting like
i feel like he's really working off of
that reference you know
taking those steps bob in the head
got the shoulders going got the arms
going this one's actually not that bad
and again going off of reference
so
the more you can use reference the
better
especially when animating like always
you guys saw how much i use reference
for my render
today
so you need to make sure you use
reference toxic i like it it's in the
running
you got a little dance you got a little
walk i feel it it feels good to me
oh my goodness okay so i just
fun fact here
um
the first toy story film didn't have ik
legs so everything from walking to
acting shots were animated with
forward kinematic legs and arms meaning
like frame by frame they had to make
sure it's stuck to the ground that's
insane
that is so much work
jeez
yeah that's craziness
let's keep going here
i'll be check
let's check it
what on earth
dude that's hilarious it looks like a
like a janky jacked up popeye man
so you got the floating situation going
on here and you're just doing the legs
like this you know
so it's a little tough
i don't know if he's
taking flight
there's a shadow and then there's no
shadow and he's looking down
whoa
[Music]
that's pretty it's pretty goofy
yeah i think this one's just a bit too
robotic
and he's floating all over the place
but it made me laugh uh in a good way i
mean i wouldn't be laughing at how bad
it is i like what you did here i think
it's awesome
all right moving on
submission okay we're looking for videos
instagram okay let me just pull this up
over here to make sure
uh
yo this is actually really good
this is really good
but let's double check that this is
yours materials
blender okay
i see you
what's the time stamp
1117 okay
makes sense
render quality is pretty on point
marvelous
i really like it
i really dig this
this feels good to me
you're definitely in the running uh
for the top five on this this is really
good
this is really awesome i i would love
for you to actually
um
render a version of this for the discord
so i can post it in the winners because
i think i think you're going to win
this is really really nice
and it loops too that's great animal
crossing it looks like um
yeah it feels organic you got the arms
kind of moving around i don't know if
that's that's bobbing up and down it
feels it feels good the hips are bobbing
up and down
you know the spider-man one was like the
hips were straight moving through z
space without bobbing up and down this
one bobs it's really good you have the
weight you have the motion
uh it feels good to me so
i like it a lot
i like it a lot marvelous put you down
in the running all right we still need
to go through them all and here's the
last one willy
not bad all right not bad you got the
lego
lego style going it looks like stop
motion
which is pretty incredible i don't know
if this is
i don't know if this is a render or not
dude
there's no materials
or clay
so i'm not sure
it could be actually hand animated
which is super cool
this one's fun i like this this one is
very fun
so between let's see all right tinum
i think tenem well okay here let's let's
just speak plainly here marvelous you're
gonna win this one congratulations
marvelous you have won the weekly
challenge
um your render is my favorite out of all
of them
it has the most character the render
quality is fantastic character has a
weight
um
it's kicking through the grass here like
this is so good this is so good i'm very
impressed
so mr marvelous media engine on
instagram
you have won the weekly challenge so
you'll get the weekly challenge roll i'm
gonna give it to you right now you'll
see it live
this is how it works boom
get that challenger winner and you pop
up on the right if you're online
we'll see you on the right side
but it looks like you're not online
today
all right we got one winner
next up let me scroll down through here
uh toxic i think you're the next one man
i think this is good you got some moves
in here
you got some feeling some rhythm going
you got the neck going back and forth
the hands locking and shaking
the feet stick to the ground so i think
toxic you are a winner this week as well
let's get you that
that challenge winner roll and there you
are you're online
and you pop up right on the right here
we'll see you there and there's
marvelous
awesome awesome
sweet alright so we got two
who's next
who will be next
this one's not this one's not bad this
one actually i think
is pretty darn good minus the ape arms
um
but
we we're not here to talk about
the model we're here to talk about the
walk cycle and i think this one is
really nice
so
it has
intention
um it has character to it it's a stroll
it's definitely a stroll
um even the hair is bobbing here that
looks really nice
so kalepsy i think that's your name
kalupsi congratulations you've won the
weekly challenge this week let's get you
that roll real quick bam challenge
winner
and we'll see you online soon thank you
thank you so much for putting in the
hard work i appreciate it it's super fun
i hope you learned something
we got two more rolls to give out here i
think um
this one here
is goofy it's super goofy it's
definitely
a janky walk cycle
and it is based off of uh cg geek video
but the toxic video was also the toxic
animation was based off of another video
as well that's okay as long as you use
it as a reference and don't copy it
um
tinum
very interesting walk cycle here but
honestly dude like why is this not your
submission
with the dancing and everything
this is hilarious
got the hands and the feet going
not bad this is this one's a bit robotic
but
i gotta get that foot tap
good times
so this is the
animation
so it's a very slow slithery walk
and it has a feel to it i can feel
this kind of like slow approach with the
hips forward and
swaying back and forth
the legs crossing over in front of each
other it's a very like feminine kind of
um
uh
like seducing almost kind of walk cycle
but you have your hands the hands that
go wide that get me a little bit
boom
the hips are forward you have the chest
moving separate from the hips and
rolling back and forth which is which is
really nice so it's between i think that
one
you know this one this one's nice by
sharp aluminum
but it's technically not a walk cycle i
guess the moonwalk i get it i get it i
think it's awesome i think you get good
work
you usually do good work on that stuff
um
i mean at the end of the day though like
this is a straight-up walk cycle though
still still a little stiff though
this is tough
this is so good though
i love this
willy i don't know man
this feels good to me i like this i like
this lego walking loop it looks real
which is classic old school animation
um
man i gotta give you some some shout
outs willie i think you've you've won
this weekly challenge
i really like it
it's a it's a great walk cycle it's a
lego walks like you got the arms and
legs your character looking at the
camera
um
it's the only one
that doesn't feel
between between
how should i say this
it feels robotic in the right way
obviously you're limited by a lego
character
but i think you did a good job
so willie congratulations you're winning
this week's weekly challenge let's get
you the challenge winner roll are you
online who knows
maybe not but
soon very soon
that's awesome yeah that's awesome i'm
i'm i will happily give that out and i
think finally
let's call it with tinum here
congratulations tenem
you're already a challenge winner that's
the thing you're already challenge
winner
so it makes sense
um congratulations you won the weekly
challenge
you know still a little like the hands
the hands like this that get me
and it's a little slow but i do get a
feeling from this and it does have
character to the walk cycle
which is
a lot harder than it may seem
so congratulations tenem and to the rest
of our winners this week who have won
the weekly challenge roll
um congrats guys i hope you won
something
and uh
yeah the challenge for this week is to
create a still life
realistic looking setup
of some fruit some vegetables some
cheese some wine you know whatever the
heck you want
the point is to get some really nice
lighting and focus on your lighting
and composition so that is the focus for
next week's weekly challenge it's going
to be thanksgiving
um
i will be streaming on on saturday as
well uh so we'll still be streaming
so we'll go through them then we'll go
through our still life's then and i hope
you guys learned something this week
something about lighting and something
about composition
you definitely want to take your shapes
and objects and rotate them and position
them in a way that you can tell what
every single shape and object is all
right
i think mine just finished
it looks like it's doing multiple frames
we don't want it to do that
27 minutes for one frame
that's how you do it
nice
okay
so we have this image here
um
i might do a little bit of photoshopping
or something but
guys i gotta bounce
it's four and a half hours into a stream
and i have
a saturday one half of a saturday to
enjoy here so
thank you guys for tuning in i
appreciate it i'll be posting this image
here on my instagram on monday
so um and i'll post anything that i do
here to this
if i do any photoshopping
in the discord server if you're not part
of the discord server definitely join it
the link is down below and also as a
reminder
myself and nvidia and pny were giving
away some awesome prizes to people in
the us this is us only because we're
sending out physical prizes
and uh
the link to
win some of those prizes it's a random
drawing a raffle you have i believe
until the 30th you have eight more days
to join this
the contest is called expanding
dimensions
it's the second part to the parallel
dimensions which was the whole render
contest but for those of you guys who
didn't have a chance to render something
this is just a random raffle for you all
um you go down here
opt-in boom check the box continue you
can do like 10 to 20 different things to
get a raffle ticket essentially
there's 10 000 entries right now
um
and like it's stuff like watch one of my
videos subscribe to my channel if you're
already subscribed you already get the
point um you know follow me on instagram
that kind of stuff follow p and y follow
nvidia
and you guys will get points to win
um an nvidia quadro rtx 4000
we also got you with an nvidia shield tv
pro it's the same prices right
um two copies of a
basically a one terabyte ssd
which if you guys don't know a
solid-state drive has no moving parts so
you can access your data a lot faster on
your computer and then two
usb 3.1 256 gigabyte flash drives so
definitely
check out expanding dimensions sign up
you know do a little do do all the stuff
get yours get you some raffle tickets
and win some prizes this is u.s only
just because there's some legal things
going down with uh not going down
but for legal reasons
were
nvidia and pen wise unable to send
physical items to
certain countries so it's going to be
u.s only um
so yeah guys thank you for joining i
hope you learned a lot
um
william says check discord what does
this chord say
i don't know
there's
there's nothing on discord
all right well
you'll have a good time i'ma bounce out
of here
um
yeah enjoy the rest of your day i hope
you guys learned something and uh i hope
you guys have a good time
working on the still life contest
because i look forward to see y'all to
seeing all of your renders it's gonna be
a good time
and uh yeah i'll catch you guys soon
i'ma bounce i'm gonna get some water for
my throat it hurts
all right guys have a good one peace